Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Moin Leute, langsam Zeit, dass ich meine Polster für das Biodynamics tausche.
Die Polster sind schon ein bisschen hart, muss mal gucken gleich was sowas kostet,
ich glaube 20€ oder so, aber besser als ein neues Headset kaufen.
Oh, ich habe mein Lautstärkeplugin ausgemacht, warum habe ich denn sowas gemacht?
Lass mal kurz was schauen, Biodynamics MMX300 Polster, so was brauche ich,
genau, echt Leder, nee, sowas hier brauche ich, das ist doch kein echt Leder, das ist halt deutlich Schaumstoff,
was die China-Chinesen da wieder für Zeug drauf schreiben, man, echt Leder, ist klar,
sowas hier brauche ich, genau, doch, da passen die, das ist ja ein DT-770 im Prinzip,
doch, doch, das passt auch, aber ich brauche auf jeden Fall mal neue,
die sind schon ein bisschen fest und bewegen sich nicht mehr richtig,
die sind ja auch schon ein paar Jahre alt, wird mal Zeit, da wieder was neues dran zu packen.
An mein neues Cancelling-Kopfhörer habe ich letztens erst welche dran gemacht,
auch so ein 15€ Ding von Amazon, funktioniert wunderbar, wobei die ein bisschen zu schnell
kaputt gegangen sind, ich hatte mir ja mal vor ein paar Jahren so den QuietComfort 35 Kopfhörer gekauft
wegen Bahnfahren und Büroarbeiten und neues Cancelling und da sind jetzt nach ein paar Jahren
schon die Polster aufgeplatzt, da habe ich mir auch gedacht, ganz schön billig, stimmt,
das ist eine gute Idee, du hast recht, das ist eine gute Idee, eigentlich könnte man die einfach
mal waschen, die Polster, ja, du hast recht, eigentlich könnte man die einfach mal waschen,
weil letztendlich, wenn ich mir das hier so angucke, letztendlich ist das hier einfach nur Stoff,
das ist eine gute Idee, das probiere ich mal, einfach mal waschen, dann sind die Dinger
wahrscheinlich wieder gut, wahrscheinlich brauche ich gar keine neue, High IQ Chat wieder,
ich sehe es schon hier, Massive, Big Brain, was war das, habt ihr auch gehört Chat,
lauwarmes Wasser, bisschen milde Seife, ja, probiere ich mal aus, ich wasche das mal,
dann ist wahrscheinlich gar nicht notwendig, dass ich neue Polster kaufe. Sonntags Team Messages,
wir haben noch ganz schön viele Videos offen, ist diese Woche irgendwas interessantes passiert,
lass mal kurz gucken, GitHub Trends, ich muss mal kurz was gucken, ob es irgendwie neue Issues
antworten oder sonst was gibt, ach guck mal, der hat geantwortet, was hat er denn geantwortet,
ok, der hat zugemacht, nice, ok, ja, was gibt es denn für GitHub Trends, was haben wir denn,
lass mal gucken, gucken wir doch ab und zu mal, lass mal schauen, was die Woche getrennt ist,
vielleicht sehen wir was spannendes dabei, Memos, Open Source Self Hosted Memo Hub,
Knowledge Management, ok, die 50.000. Notizen App oder wie, sieht aus wie Mac OS Only,
wenn ich mir das anschaue, Demo Host, was hostet der denn, was soll es überhaupt sein,
Live Demo, ok, zeig her, was bin ich sehend, sign in, ok, was passiert jetzt,
liegt jetzt eine neue Instanz an unter der, ah ja, ok, es ist eine Notizen Anwendung,
na zum Glück hat hier keine irgendwelche Bubas gepostet und ich werde jetzt gebannt worden,
man weiß ja nie was da drin passiert, das mache ich jetzt auch zu, weil ich weiß,
es lockt sich jetzt irgendeiner ein und postet irgendeinen Pornbild, einfach nur,
damit ich es im Stream aus Versehen zeige, Massive Subscription, also irgendeine für Teams
Notizverwaltung, ok, weiß nicht, inwieweit man das braucht, ehrlich gesagt, aber gut,
scheint ja gut anzukommen auf Shithub, so, was ist denn sonst noch, Cheat Punkt, SH,
das habe ich mal ausprobiert, das verstehe ich, den Reiz da dran nicht, Moment, ein neues
Source Control System, also quasi ein Git Konkurrent, oder wie in Rust, naja, es ist
in Rust, dann ist es schon mal Blazingly Fast und Written in Rust, dann ist es ja schon mal
prinzipiell gut geeignet, um auf Hacker News gepostet zu werden, ist das dieser Fork von,
wie heißt das andere, Macurial, Macurial, oder irgendwie so, wie ist das denn, das da,
ist das der Facebook Fork davon, ich habe irgendwo mal gelesen, Facebook hätte das
geforkt oder so, naja, hier, da steht es doch, Moin GamerXD, ok, weil das von Facebook ist,
ist es natürlich dann Rust und Blazingly Fast und ganz toll und alle müssen es verwenden,
ok, ich habe bis jetzt ehrlich gesagt, also es gibt ja viele Sachen wo ich halt benutze
und mir denke so, ich benutze es halt so, weil es nicht besseres gibt, so NPM oder so, oder
LibreOffice oder, es gibt viele Sachen wo ich mir denke, ja ich benutze die halt manchmal,
weil man sie benutzen muss, nicht weil sie so geil sind, sondern weil es halt so das Beste
ist was man so benutzen kann aktuell, wenn es was Neues gebe, was Besseres würde ich
auch benutzen, aber bei Git hatte ich bis jetzt ehrlich gesagt noch nie irgendwie das
Bedürfnis großartig was anderes zu nehmen, eh Microsoft Office zackt, ist ja noch schlimmer,
ich benutze LibreOffice eigentlich auch so gut wie nicht, das einzige wozu ich es verwende
ist ab und zu mal eine Rechnung als PDF exportieren und das liegt auch nur daran, weil ich bisher
zu faul war das irgendwie in Markdown zu machen, ok, IPTV, Collection of Publicly Available
IPTV Channels, ok das heißt wenn man nur mit öffentlich-rechtlichen Sender auskommt, kann
man das alles da drüber gucken, also ich gehe mal nicht von aus, dass es dort, also ich gucke
eh kein Fernsehen mehr, mir ist das eh wurscht, ich gucke weder irgendwie Pro7 RTL und sowas
noch gucke ich irgendwie großartig ARD, ZDF, gucke manchmal vielleicht irgendwelche Ausschnitte
auf YouTube von irgendwelchen Sendungen, ok, aber im Großen und Ganzen bin ich eigentlich
schon seit Jahren, man könnte fast sagen Jahrzehnten Fernsehfrei, also ich glaube ich gucke seit
was weiß ich 2005 oder so, nicht mehr regelmäßig Fernsehen, ich will es seit es jetzt so viel
YouTube Content gibt, Twitch und die letzten ja einige Jahre jetzt auch schon, VOD, also
Video on Demand, Streaming Seiten von Amazon bis Netflix, also Fernsehen, ich weiß nicht
wie es bei euch aussieht, aber mir ist Fernsehen eigentlich gar nicht mehr angesagt, also normales
Fernsehen gucken, so mit aufnehmen, könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern als man früher
Sachen aufgenommen hat, dann muss man die Werbung überspulen und solche Dinger, ok
was ist Flipper, ich habe keine Ahnung, was ist Flipper Zero, das ist wieder so ein Projekt
wo ich keine Ahnung habe was es ist, Flipper Zero, was ist Flipper Zero, ah Krypto Zeug,
was ich habe ok jetzt mal ernsthaft Leute, ich habe jetzt die Projektseite gesehen, ich
habe absolut nicht den Hauch einer Ahnung was ich hier überhaupt sehe, was ist das,
ist das eine Kryptowährung, ist es Flipper weil es ein komischer Delfin ist oder, ich
weiß nicht was es ist, was ist Flipper, darf man danach googeln, Flipper Zero ist ein tragbares
Tamagotchi ähnliches Multifunktions, ok damit hätte ich gar nicht gerechnet, ich dachte
das hat irgendwas mit Kryptowährung zu tun, aber nee das ist voll nur Donations für den
Typ, achso, ach das ist quasi wo man so Sachen wie, nee es ist nicht, ich dachte sowas wo
man Autoschlüssel weiterleiten kann und sowas, so wireless Autoschlüssel, na doch Tags,
ok das ist quasi, wenn man wieder Lockpicking Lawyer sein will, aber digital, ok verstehe,
das ist aber jetzt mal ein gutes Projekt hier, ich habe zwar keine Ahnung bis jetzt gehabt
was es ist, aber es klingt von allem noch hier am sinnvollsten, Whisper Cpp, ok Machine Learning
für C++, warum will man sich das frei will, ja gut wahrscheinlich weil manches anderes
zu lahm ist, beziehungsweise Integration oftmals schwierig, aber ok, warum nicht, Novo Open
Source Notification Platform, ja wahrscheinlich wieder für nicht außer IOS, für alles außer
IOS, wollen wir wetten für alles außer IOS, Kecke, IOS, ach nee das ist quasi nur so
ein Meta Framework für unterschiedliche Notification Services, achso, ok, ja weil Notifications
funktionieren ja auf IOS nicht so gescheit, wenn man die nicht quasi über Apple schicken
will und wenn man die nicht per Native App machen will, also zum Beispiel Notifications
für eine PWA ist soweit ich weiß unter IOS nicht möglich, unter Android ist das seit
vier Jahren oder so schon, in 4-5 Jahren schon kein Problem mehr, Unify Package Manager,
ok das ist was für Mac, Machine Learning Zeug, ja mit Swift App sag ich ja, ja aber
du kannst, kannst du, ok das ist die Frage, kannst du eine PWA machen, die mit Firebase
Connected und Notifications da drüber schickt, also die normalen Web Notifications kann IOS
auf jeden Fall nicht, sind wir jetzt stehen geblieben, da, ne, nein, da, fuck, da, Type
Save Router Build und bla bla bla bla, ok das wäre so ein Ding wo ich gar nicht wüsste
wozu ich das brauchen würde, ok, aber ich bin halt auch nicht im Type Script Frontend
Game, dass ich mich da groß auskennen würde, GoToSocial, Fast Fun Active Pub Server, powered
by Go, ganz wichtig, es ist nicht written in Rust, aber es ist powered by Go, das ist
das nächstbeste Ding was es gibt, was ist das überhaupt, Fast Fun Activity Pub Server,
Powerful and Dangerous Goblin, was, was bin ich, was ist das überhaupt, das ist quasi
Twitter, Self Hosted Twitter, nun ja, na gut, warum nicht, Machine Learning Zeug, China
Chinesen Zeug, Engine X Config Generator, ok, das ist gar nicht mal übel, wenn es viele,
also kompliziertere Settings unterstützt, wenn es die komplizierteren Settings unterstützt,
das ist gar nicht schlecht, weil, ich meine, die Engine X Config ist jetzt zwar gar nicht
so abartig wie eine Apache Config oder sowas, aber auch immerhin schon nicht so einfach,
ok jetzt soll man hier irgendwas generieren und dann sagt man was, und wie Generated
man das jetzt, ach hier, hier ist meine Generated Config, das ist eigentlich eine coole Sache,
ja, Subbot, das ist eigentlich gar nicht schlecht, mich hat mich wundert, was noch
keiner da ein Webinterface für gebaut hat, es gibt ja diesen Engine X Proxy Manager,
da kannst du aber die Sachen, die sich jetzt nicht um Zertifikate und Reverse Proxy drehen
eigentlich auch nur von Hand über das Webinterface eintragen, gut, braucht man ja auch ehrlich
gesagt nicht wirklich, ich meine, wie oft ändert sich auf einem Server so eine Engine
X Config, eigentlich gar nicht, die baust du für den Server bzw. für den Dienst oder
was auch immer da drauf ist und dann bleibt die statisch und wenn hast du es meistens
eh über irgendein Config Management System oder ganz davor als eigene Kiste, also, ja,
eigentlich, ja gut, da habe ich mir eigentlich selbst beantwortet, warum da noch einer kein
Webinterface für gebaut hat, man braucht es einfach nicht, Golang LRU, ein Golang, Leute,
ich kann euch sogar sagen, wofür die Abkürzung steht, LRU ist Last Recently Used, also sprich
das was zuletzt, also im Prinzip sowas hier, Notepad, sowas hier, das ist quasi eine Last
Recently Used Liste, nur, dass halt die Sachen, die zuletzt benutzt wurden, gecasht werden
anscheinend, ist es Last oder ist es Least, ist es Last, Least wäre ja bescheuert, ist
es Least, fuck, naja, komm, am längsten nicht verwenden, ok, ok, es ist Least Recently
Used, der war ein ganzes Abkürzungsteu, ich kann mir das schon mal vertun, chat, chat,
wusstet ihr das oder habt ihr auch nachgeguckt, 50-50 Chance, ja, was haben wir hier, Scrap
Time DB, Written in Rust, dann ist alles gut, würde ich gar keinen Sinn machen, anscheinend
schon, was wird hier gekrappt, Open Source Cloud Native Distributed, Alter, mehr Sachen
bitte schön zusammen, Open Source Cloud Native Distributed Time Series Database, Crap Time
DB, ach Moment, ich dachte, das ist ein Tool, um Time DB zu durchsuchen, das ist die Datenbank
oder was, Next Generation Hybrid Time Series Analytics Processing Database in the Cloud,
jetzt wissen wir Bescheid, Leute, ich hoffe euch ist jetzt allen klar, was es macht, oder
obviously, also ich glaube, jetzt, Cringe wäre jetzt nicht versteht, um was es da geht,
Written in Rust, Leute, seriously, ich werde jetzt gar nicht halten auf dem Projekt, auf
dem Projekt rumhalten, ich kenn's nicht, aber wenn der erste und wichtigste Punkt bei einem
Projekt ist, dass es Written in Rust ist, dann ist es meistens nicht, weil das Projekt
sinnvoll ist, sondern weil irgendwie einer mal wieder was in Rust neu, das Rad neu erfinden
wollte, okay, mit Webseiten ist hier schon mal nicht allzu, what, okay, warum war immer
dieses Rändern gerade kaputt war, okay, Stonks, für Stonks ist das gut, gut, ich hab keine
Ahnung, Time Series Database, ja, das hab ich verstanden, aber ansonsten, warum man das
verwenden sollte, ich weiß es nicht, ganz einfach, ich warte einfach, bis Fire Ship
ein Video drüber macht, dann weiß ich Bescheid, was es ist, Scalability, Analytical Capabilities,
Efficiency, Elasticity, okay, mir ist nicht ganz klar, wofür ich das brauchen würde,
aber gut, Crap Time DB, Rust benutzen ja gar nicht mal so viele, Rust ist einfach nur in
Open Source kreisen und in, bei für neue Projekte sehr beliebt, so insgesamt ist die Usage
von Rust gar nicht so hoch und ich muss auch ehrlich sagen, ich glaube auch nie, dass Rust
so eine, so eine 0-15 Sprache wird, die man einfach für alles jederzeit so verwenden will,
weil Rust ist echt nicht ohne, also Rust ist ziemlich kompliziert und Rust ist auch sehr
komplex und es hat seinen Daseinsberechtigung, ja, gerade für Software, wo du halt Performance
brauchst plus eben so eine gewisse Sicherheit, dass du, gut, ich meine, du kannst es in Rust
unsafe bauen, du kannst in Rust auch im Zweifelsfall auf Array Element zugreifen, die es nicht
gibt und dann muss Rust nach wie vor, wenn es nicht im Vorfeld weiß, irgendeinen Runtime
Check machen, aber du kannst halt mit Rust von vornherein viele Fehler, die zu Sicherheitsproblemen
führen könnten, irgendwelche Overflows oder ähnliche Sachen halt von vornherein ausschließen,
das hat ja schon seine Daseinsberechtigung, aber so für die 0-15 Anwendung glaube ich
nicht, dass Rust jemals so die Standard Sprache werden wird.
Überlegt euch mal, das 0-8-15 interne Zeiterfassungstool, ja, zum Beispiel, warum alles in der Welt
sollte man das in Rust programmieren, das Backend, außer man will sich das Leben schwer
machen und fünfmal länger brauchen als irgendjemand, der es in Java, C-Sharp, Python, Go oder sonst
was macht.
Ja gut, man kann sagen, unsere Zeiterfassung ist Placingly fast written in Rust, aber das
wird wahrscheinlich den Chef noch interessieren, aber den Abteilungsleiter oben drüber schon
nicht mehr, wenn es fünfmal länger dauert.
Okay, was haben wir noch, Flatbuffers, Memory Efficient Serialization Library, wisst ihr,
wisst ihr was ich nicht verstehe, warum serialisiert man überhaupt in C++ was, man kann es einfach
zu Bites casten und in der Datei schreiben und dann wieder da rausladen.
Würdest du sagen, man sollte Go lernen, ja, natürlich kommt es immer drauf an, was du
machen willst, natürlich kommt es immer ein bisschen drauf an, was du machen willst,
um das Lernenswillens und ein bisschen Übersicht zu haben, ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll.
Wenn du jetzt vielleicht sogar noch ein Projekt im Hinterkopf hast, wo du sagst, da wird sich
das für eignen, ja, warum nicht, aber wenn du ein spezielles Projekt machen willst, würde
ich eh das nehmen, was dafür am besten geeignet ist.
Es macht jetzt keinen Sinn, eine Webseite zu bauen und die irgendwie halb in Go zu machen
und dann als WebAssembly zu kompilieren, nur dass du es im Browser verwenden kannst,
kannst du einfach mit JavaScript machen.
Aber so insgesamt ist Go lernen schon sinnvoll, Go ist eines der gehyptesten Sprachen seit
den letzten Jahren schon, eines der verbreiteten Sprachen und gerade so im Cloud Umfeld ist
sehr vieles an Tools, ja, von das ganze Docker, Kubernetes Zeug bis Terraform und so was,
das ist alles, also sehr, sehr vieles ist in Go, das schadet nicht, generell schadet
es eigentlich so gut wie keine Programmiersprache, sich anzugucken, ja, vielleicht außer C++.
C++ ist das einzige, wo ich sagen würde, Leute, spart euch, wenn es nicht unbedingt
notwendig ist.
Give it a go, genau, ansonsten ist alles sinnvoll, auch Swift, ja, man kann sich das ja durchaus
mal angucken.
Also, wenn man, wenn man sich vier, fünf Sprachen aussuchen könnte, würde ich sagen,
auf jeden Fall JavaScript, kommst du nicht dran vorbei, JavaScript, Go, diesmal ist gar
kein Python Projekt dabei, das würde ich mir nämlich auch, Ruby, Python, so, das würde
ich mir pauschal schon mal angucken, dass es nicht verkehrt, Python, JavaScript, Go,
dann sowas wie C Sharp und Java eventuell noch, weil das eben im Enterprise Umfeld nach wie
vor nicht nur sehr beliebt ist, sondern weiterhin beliebt bleiben wird und was C Sharp angeht
auch eher noch beliebter wird, auch aktuell und die letzten Jahre schon, tja, und als
Fünftes kann man sich dann irgendwas abgedrehtes raussuchen, ne, können wir nicht TypeScript
sagen, ne, zum Einstieg nicht TypeScript, muss man sich nicht mit beschäftigen am Anfang,
wenn man einfach ein bisschen Webseiten basteln will und so die Basics lernen möchte, muss
man sich ja nicht mit TypeScript auseinandersetzen, ich mach bis heute so gut für nix in TypeScript,
ich bin kein hauptberuflicher Frontend Programmierer, aber wir haben ja schon ein paar Frontend
Sachen gemacht im Stream, bisher war das immer JavaScript, ich hab mir aber überlegt, ob
wir nicht demnächst mal ein bisschen TypeScript lernen sollten wieder, weil ich hab bei Hackernews
letztens, letztens, ist auch gut, ist auch scheiße, gut, ist auch wieder ein paar Monate
her, ich hab letztens bei Hackernews einen Blogartikel gefunden, da hat irgendwie einer
eine Regex Engine rein im TypeScript Typesystem gebaut, die kann wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht
alles oder nicht so krass viel, aber sie matcht anscheinend das ein oder andere, ich hab keine
Ahnung wie er das gemacht hat, geschweige denn warum das überhaupt möglich ist, aber
ich weiß, dass das in anderen Sprachen auch schon gemacht wurde, also in Ruby, in Ruby
hat das glaube ich auch schon mal einer hingebracht, dass er, ne in Ruby war es umgedreht, in Ruby
war es umgedreht, sorry Leute, in Ruby war es umgedreht, in Ruby hat jemand in der Ruby
Regex Engine eine Programmiersprache gebaut, die so basic Sachen konnte wie Schleifen und
sowas, Schleifen und Ausgabe und so, da hat quasi eine Programmiersprache in Regex gebaut,
hab ich auch gedacht, was mit den Leuten verkehrt, Videovorschlag, in sieben Tagen zum Pro Gamer,
das haben wir uns letztens angeguckt schon, wie genau gehst du voran, wenn du eine Programmiersprache
lernst, ja meistens liegt das bei mir daran, weil ich irgendwas machen will und dann feststelle
ah, das würde sich jetzt besonders gut dafür eignen, zum Beispiel weil es da für eine
super Library gibt, die quasi konkurrenzlos gut ist, zum Beispiel Go, wenn man Sachen
mit WebRTC machen will auf Serverseite, WebRTC ist ja eigentlich was, was komplett für
Browser gedacht ist, ja zum Beispiel Videokonferenzen im Browser und Chat, also Sprache und sowas
geht ja eigentlich komplett alles über WebRTC heutzutage, aber wenn man jetzt beispielsweise
WebRTC nicht im Browser machen will, sondern vielleicht mit einem Server Backend und dem
Browser, dann braucht man irgendeine gute WebRTC Library und da ist tatsächlich Go
die Sprache mit der besten WebRTC Library, nicht mit diesem Ding hier, das kann so gut
wie alles was man braucht, WebRTC technisch hat nicht umsonst 10.000 Sterne und es ist
sinnvoll, sinnvoll zu programmieren damit und dann würde ich mir in dem Fall, wenn ich
damit was machen will, Go angucken, weil es halt das ist, was ich vorhabe zu machen und
es die beste Library dafür gibt, ansonsten ehrlich gesagt gucke ich mir als erstes mal
paar Tutorials an, gucke ich mal ob es irgendwelche so Getting Started Sachen gibt, mal so drüber
scrollen und dann ist das beste einfach anfangen, anfangen, sobald man feststellt, oh Mist,
jetzt weiß ich nicht wie es geht, googeln, weitermachen, googeln, also im Prinzip 80%
googeln oder bingen oder DuckDuckGone oder was gibt es denn sonst noch so, leg gerade,
was ist denn noch so für Suchmaschinen die aktuell, Yahoo, nee, nee, wirklich nett, wirklich
nett, gibt es sonst noch, früher gab es noch Alter Vista und Fireball und solche Sachen
aber StarPage, Ask, Ask.com gab es früher noch und sowas, ich weiß nicht ob das Zeug
überhaupt noch irgendjemand verwendet, also Yahoo ist wahrscheinlich in Japan noch beliebt,
ich habe nie verstanden warum Leute Yahoo verwenden, welcher Ausbildung würdest du
empfehlen um in IT einzusteigen oder reicht es wenn ich mir selber Sachen beibringe, naja,
wenn du dir ein paar Sachen selber beigebracht hast, ob das reicht dann, dass dich da für
jemand einstellt weiß ich nicht, also die einfachste Variante, also je nachdem, wenn
du aber was vorzuweisen hast warum nicht, aber so nach dem Motto ich habe mal irgendwie
einen Python Udemy Kurs gemacht, ich würde da jetzt, ich meine wobei auf der anderen
Seite aktuell ist der Mangel an Leuten so groß, ich stelle da alles ein, aber auf der
anderen Seite, also das beste was du als Ausbildung machen kannst ist nach wie vor gibt ja nichts
anderes, du kannst Fachinformatiker Systemintegration lernen oder Fachinformatiker Anwendungsentwicklung
oder einen der neuen Fachinformatiker, ich habe aber schon wieder vergessen wie es heißt,
Fachinformatiker Netzwerk, wie heißen diese neuen, wie heißen diese Digger, was, ok,
es gibt jetzt nämlich noch Daten und Prozessanalyse und digitale Vernetzung, da habe ich noch nie
Ausbildungsplätze dafür gesehen, ja, genau, richtig, letztendlich kommt es darauf an wo
du es machst, ja, KI Kunst mit Arte, na gut, wenn ich schon Gebühren bezahle, Web.de, ach
das gibt es ja auch noch, ja stimmt ja, das ist aber doch bestimmt gar keine eigene Suche
Web.de oder, das ist doch bestimmt irgendwelche unter der Haube benutzen die Google oder so,
das kommt ganz entscheidend darauf an wo man seine Ausbildung macht, in was es, in welche
Richtung es geht, aber ich habe jetzt bei meiner Jobsuche gelernt, sowas wie Systemadministrator
ist outdated, sowas nennt sich heute Linux Engineer, hier haben wir ein bisschen rumgeguckt
und Linux Engineer ist angesagt jetzt oder DevOps Engineer oder Cloud Engineer, so jetzt
haben wir uns angeguckt was in GitHub trendet und festgestellt ist nichts dabei was ich
unbedingt mir angucken muss, das interessiert mich was es ist, aber ja, ich wüsste jetzt
nicht wozu, alles klar, easy, was gucken wir uns denn jetzt an, habe ich noch irgendwas
vergessen, dann seid ihr richtig oldschool, na ne das gibt es schon immer noch, aber vermehrt
heißt das heutzutage XYZ Engineer, das kommt darauf an was die Firma damit macht, das ist
doch alles nicht festgeschrieben, also anhand der Jobbezeichnung kannst du ja heutzutage
eh nur noch sehr grob erkennen was du eigentlich wirklich machen wirst, deswegen ist es gut
wenn die Stellenanzeigen ein bisschen ausführlicher sind und Aufgabengebiete drin stehen, weil
rein anhand des Titels kann das, ich meine es konnte früher schon alles sein aber jetzt
auch, gerade in der IT, die suchen irgendeinen Job, du guckst dir den Titel an und denkst
dir du weißt was passiert, na wollen die was ganz anderes, Babbel, Dankeschön für den
Sub, huge subscriptions, oder wie es mein Englischlehrer früher übersetzt hat, danke für das Subskribieren,
er hat ja ernsthaft Subscription mit Subskribieren übersetzt, aber gut der war auch ein Jahr vor
Rente, der hat sowas wie Youtube und sowas damals noch nicht mitbekommen, obwohl es das
auch schon gab, ich mein Berufsschule war 2007, Youtube gibt es seit 2005, ne genau,
du bist Systems Engineer, siehste, macht sich auch besser, wenn man Engineer ist, Auto-Aiming,
das haben wir glaube ich sogar schon mal geguckt, das ist schon ein bisschen älter, so was
können wir uns jetzt mal anschauen, was haben wir denn hier, Sony, oh, wir lassen uns eine
Runde Level-Capture baiten, Sony says Battlefield can't compete, naja, hat Sony ganz schön
lange dafür gebraucht um das festzustellen, aber war ganz im Ernst, die haben sich halt
selbst verkackt, ok, komm wir lassen uns eine Runde Level-Capture baiten, eine Runde Level-Capture
baiten, was, Battlefield, nein, das hätte ich jetzt ja nie gedacht, hat er, hat er gerade
gesagt Battlefield 4, Moment, ich muss mal kurz, Moment, wo habe ich denn hier meinen
Pro-Process Explorer, irgendwie ist mein Rechner etwas laggy gerade, was laggt hier rum, nix,
ok nice, chat, wer von euch ist es, wegen wem laggt mein Rechner, was ist hier los,
du pings gerade, dann mach mal ping aus, Endmap aus, ping aus, Trace Route aus, es piekt in
Season 3, ja gut, es war auch nicht schwierig zu pieken, so, also, auf geht's, Level-Capture,
Level-Captureated, ok,soo,
haben für und gegen diesen Deal geredet. Activisions Call of Duty Franchise hat
unvergesslich die größte Aufmerksamkeit, Microsofts Nr.1-Kompetitor Sony hat
den Deal so viel wie möglich zurückgezogen, dass, wenn Microsoft Cod ein Xbox-Exklusiv
machen würde, es massiv schaden würde, Sony's Verkauf. Diese Woche ist Sony
ausgesprochen, dass es keine anderen Game-Franchise gibt, die mit Cod konkurrieren können. Sie
haben z.B. Battlefield ausgeliefert und gesagt, wie EA ein Rival produzieren konnte. Sony hat
auch interessante Verkaufsfiguren für beide Franchise veröffentlicht.
Mehr als 400 Millionen Kopien von Call of Duty wurden auf PlayStation verkauft,
während nur 88 Millionen Kopien von Battlefield wurden verkauft. Das betrifft die Franchise,
nicht nur Modern Warfare 2 und 2042. Und obwohl viele Fans glauben, dass Sony einfach Fakten
sagen, sieht es sehr aggressiv aus, wenn sie ihren Partner, EA, so nennen. Und natürlich
gibt es hier viel mehr unvergessliche Nuancen, wie Call of Duty Call of Duty
produziert viel mehr Titel als Battlefield in der gleichen Zeit.
Für Call of Duty News sind viele Leakers online berichtet, dass Modern Warfare 2 in
Dezember einen Free-to-Play-Weekend hosten wird. Es wird zwischen Dezember 15 und 19
stattfinden, nachdem die Saison 1 veröffentlicht wurde. Das ist der erste der vielen
Free-to-Play-Weekends, die live im Game-Life-Zycle gehen werden. Es ist unklar, ob
die Free-to-Play-Weekende die Game Single-Player oder die Multi-Player
anbieten werden. Denn die neuen DMZ-Extraction-Modes sind bereits Free-to-Play.
Wie findest du das? Ist das Werbung? Ist es deine Seite? Ist das Five-Hat-High-IQ-Werbung?
Das will ich jetzt wissen, bevor ich das einklinge.
Nein? Okay, zeig mal her. Ich glaub dir, dass das nicht deine Seite ist. Weiter Bildung zum
Programmierer. Die Frage ist nicht so sehr, ob man dann irgendwie so einen Kurs gemacht hat
oder nicht, sondern ob das irgendjemand interessiert, also ob es deine Chancen
wirklich verbessert. Gibt ja bei den Amis auch viele Bootcamps, dass es in Deutschland
jetzt eher weniger verbreitet. Als Quereinsteiger in drei bis fünf Monaten zu einem
gefragten Web-Programmierer. Anschließend ersten Job in der Frontend-Backend-Fullstack-In.
In neun Monaten machst du alles. Alles klar. Die Digitalisierung ist jetzt auch in Deutschland
voll angekommen. Auf dem Jobmarkt suchen gerade überall tolle Unternehmen. Da hab ich so mal
Zweifel, ob es alles tolle Unternehmen sind, aber okay. Das stimmt. Es ist insofern schon
richtig. Die suchen alle Hände ringt, Leute. Ähm, wer ist denn das? Den Kerl hab ich schon mal
irgendwo gesehen auf YouTube, glaub ich. Das hab ich schon, den hab ich schon mal
irgendwo gesehen.
Okay, bla, bla, bla. Den Kerl hab ich auch schon mal irgendwo auf YouTube gesehen.
Ähm, keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt. Es ist halt die Frage, ob es jemand am Ende interessiert,
ob du so einen Kurs gemacht hast oder nicht. Müssen wir sich jetzt mal im Detail angucken.
Grad jetzt so pauschal nichts zu sagen. So, mal gucken, was Sony weiter erzählt.
Ich hab mich grad aus Versehen angeklickt. Ich hab mich grad selbst erschreckt, warum einmal
Voice Sounds hier kommen. Ich war noch auf einem falschen Bildschirm. Ey, Leute, Leute,
wie wär's, wenn die mal wieder ein neues Splinter Cell Game machen, was was taugt?
Ganz einfach so. Und vielleicht ohne Türme erobern? Das muss man bei Ubisoft mittlerweile
dabei sagen, weil in jedem Ubisoft Game werden Türme erobert. Kommt das auch auf den PC?
Kommt das auch auf den PC oder ist PC schon immer Next-Gen? Und muss man das neu kaufen,
wenn man's schon hat, auf dem PC wahrscheinlich, oder? Ich frage jetzt, ob die ganzen Nots dann
funktionieren auch. Ah, Free for All Owners. Ich glaube, dann werde ich mir auch mal wieder
eine Runde Witcher 3 geben. Das ist schon immer noch eines der nicest RPGs, die so gibt.
Das ist doch das von den ehemaligen
oder von einigen der ehemaligen Dead Space Leuten, oder? Das habe ich, glaube ich, noch
im Hinterkopf. Warum? Ich dachte, das ist ein Single-Player-Game. Warum? Ich dachte,
das ist ein Single-Player-Game. Warum? bloß ab und an einen
Allerdings begannen die Fans, Dinge zu fragen, wenn sie die vergangenen Szenen entdeckten,
würde auch 25 neue Death Animations zusätzlich geben.
13 für den spielbaren Charakter und 12 für die Gegner.
Mit viel von dem Spiels Marketing konzentriert sich auf den neuen Gore-Engine und die Death Animations,
waren die Fans überrascht, dass viele dieser Animations hinter einem Geldstuhl waren.
Schofield hat auf Twitter gewechselt.
Er hat die Fans überrascht, dass die 25 Death Animations nicht von der Basis-Game entdeckt werden.
Vielmehr werden sie spezifisch für die Saison passen.
Er sagt, die Devs werden nur auf die neuen Animations in dem neuen Jahr arbeiten.
Overwatch 2s Saison 2 wird am 6. Dezember eröffnen.
Und Blizzard hat gesagt, dass sie in den kommenden Tagen neue Content aufreißen werden.
Ich bin mal echt gespannt, ob es Blizzard diesmal schafft, für nennenswerte Zeit ordentlich Content zu liefern.
Am Anfang von Overwatch hatten die ja riesen Probleme.
Da haben die ja teilweise Monate für gebraucht.
Es kam ein Patch raus,
irgendwas war total broken und kaputt.
Und es hat dann erst mal drei Monate gedauert, wo man sich damit rumschlagen musste.
Da sind sie mittlerweile besser geworden, aber immer noch nicht in bereich...
Also, als ich mir das das letzte Mal angeguckt habe, aber immer noch nicht in dem Bereich, wie ich mir das gewünscht hätte.
Weil ganz im Ernst, eigentlich sollte man doch darauf gucken, dass man, wenn man Spiele heutzutage rausbringt,
Multiplayer-Spiele, die einen gewissen Competitive Aspekt haben, dass man das möglichst schnell patchen kann.
Schnell heißt innerhalb von paar Tagen.
Am besten, dass man gleich, und sogar ich mein Call of Duty kriegt sowas hin,
dass man im Zweifelsfall auch Sachen direkt deaktivieren kann, sollte es wirklich große Glitches geben.
Ich denke mal, das können sie mittlerweile.
Ansonsten ist halt die Frage, ob es Blizzard diesmal schafft, mehr als ab und zu mal einen Comic
und ab und zu mal irgendwie eine Map zu liefern.
Das ist halt nichts, was die Leute langfristig schockt.
Außerdem bin ich eh gespannt, wann endlich mal ihr Singleplayer-Modus kommt.
Overwatch 2 wurde ja ursprünglich angekündigt, also der Hauptaufhänger damals, um Overwatch 2 anzukündigen,
war ja der Singleplayer-Modus.
Oder besser gesagt, dieser PvE-Modus.
Nicht wirklich Singleplayer-Modus, der PvE-Modus ist es ja eher.
Und davon hat man jetzt erstaunlich wenig gesehen in letzter Zeit.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wann das kommt.
Overwatch 2 PvE Release Date.
2023, ja siehst du.
Dann ist halt die nächste Frage, warum, und das habe ich bis heute nicht so genau verstanden,
warum genau ist es eigentlich Overwatch 2?
Ich meine, ja man sieht, dass sich grafisch ein bisschen was getan hat.
Die Helden sehen teilweise ein bisschen detaillierter aus, aber ich meine jetzt nicht so wirklich wahnsinnig großer Unterschied.
Also wenn du jemand was zeigst auf Overwatch 1 und Overwatch 2,
ich glaube nicht, dass so die meisten Leute direkt den Unterschied erkennen können.
Also es ist ja nichts drin, es sind irgendwie 4-5 neue Helden oder so gibt es jetzt insgesamt.
Ich habe gestern erst wieder einen neuen Ankündigungs-Trailer für einen Held gesehen.
Sie haben alte Maps, die haben die 2CP-Maps, haben sie entfernt und haben dafür diesen neuen,
ich weiß gar nicht wie der heißt, dieser Schiebemodus eingeführt.
An ansonsten, mein, viel hat sich da nicht getan.
Es ist jetzt Free2Play und es hat eine 2 im Namen.
Also im Prinzip könnte man sagen, es war ein Free2Play-Relaunch mit einer 2 im Titel,
dass es sich abgrenzt vom ersten, obwohl es eigentlich das erste ist.
Ist damit Version 1 eingestampft? Ja, Version 1 gibt es nicht mehr.
Erinnert sich noch jemand an den Tracer-Hinten-Skandal am Anfang von Overwatch?
Das war auch so ein Ding, wo sich alle aufgeregt haben und ich mir gedacht habe,
Mensch habt ihr Probleme.
Also wer sich daran erinnern kann, Tracer hatte eine Victory-Pose in dem Spiel,
wo man sie von hinten gesehen hat, wo dann quasi der Tracer-Pobbes schön in der Mitte war.
Und das Zentrum des Bildes war Tracers Hintern.
Da gab es damals eine riesen Aufregung, ach so, und irgendjemand hat herausgefunden,
das wäre angeblich eine ehemalige Playboy-Pose gewesen.
Und das ist ja ganz furchtbar schrecklich.
Und da wurde sich damals wahnsinnig drüber aufgeregt.
Und daraufhin hat Blizzard das deaktiviert und entfernt,
weil sie ja nicht wollten, dass sich irgendjemand unsaved oder so fühlt in dem Game.
Bloß, das damals, das fand ich dann eigentlich schon irgendwie ein bisschen gebaited von Blizzard.
Die haben dann eine andere Tracer-Pose reingemacht,
wo nicht ganz so viel Fokus auf den Hintern von Tracer gelegt wurde.
Und da hat dann jemand herausgefunden, das wäre angeblich auch eine Playboy-Pose.
Aber das haben sie ja nicht wieder entfernt.
Generell Overwatch hatte schon gerade am Anfang einige Kontroversen.
Zum Beispiel, wo es diesen Comic gab,
wo man gesehen hat, dass Tracer eine Freundin hat.
Und wo sich dann die Leute auch sogar darüber aufgeregt haben.
Die hätten sich lieber um ihre Mitarbeiter kümmern sollen, die sich unsaved fühlen.
Korrekt, das stimmt wohl.
Und zumindest wurde sich dann darüber auch aufgeregt,
dass Tracer lesbisch ist laut diesem Comic,
weil, und jetzt kommt die bescheuertste Begründung, die ich je gehört habe,
weil Tracer ein Charakter ist, der explizit für das männliche Auge entworfen wurde.
Und deswegen geht das überhaupt nicht.
Und ich habe mir damals schon gedacht, hätten sie jetzt Zarya genommen
und hätten gesagt, die ist lesbisch,
dann wären die gleichen Leute gekommen, hätten sich aufgeregt.
Russische Bodybuilder, Klischees, was auch immer.
Und hätten sich darüber aufgeregt.
Du kannst es den Leuten einfach nicht recht machen, was das angeht.
Das ist unglaublich bescheuert.
Okay, nächstes.
Haben wir irgendwann mal die Zombie Games hinter uns?
Seit wie vielen Jahren gibt es Zombie Survival Games jetzt?
15 Jahre? Und das hört nicht auf?
Juckt mich überhaupt gar nicht.
Aber ich habe noch die Musik an.
Ach Forge, ist es jetzt? Ist es soweit?
Ja, es ist schon in der Vergangenheit.
Es wurde schon in der Vergangenheit belästigt.
Osurbis, Osurbis.
Aber saja.
DMR-Type-Weapon, den M392-Bandit und einem neuen Smoker-Grenade-Gadget.
Star Citizen's Entwickler haben dieses Wochenende ein neues Konzept-Schiff entdeckt, als Teil
des Intergalactic Aerospace Expo On-Going Celebration & Free-Fly Event.
Das Schiff heißt die RSI Galaxy.
Es hat eine modulierte Inzidenz, die die Funktionalität des Schiffes anbieten wird.
Diese Modelle werden einen Kargo-Modul, einen Refinery-Modul und sogar einen Medikamenten-Modul
entdecken.
Es ist größer als die bereits sehr großartige Constellation, die einen der größten Schiffe
der Spieler nutzen kann.
Was wir bisher wissen, kommt aus dem neuesten Inside Star Citizen-Episode, das war meistens
ein Konzept-Preview des Schiffes.
Heute werden wir noch mehr Details finden, z.B. den Preis für den Konzept-Schiff.
Spielt jemand von euch regelmäßig?
Ich meine, Star Citizen ist ja immer ein Game, was du seit einer Weile spielen kannst und
auch wohl recht viel, so zumindest Exploring technisch, recht viel Umfang hat.
Mich spricht es nicht an und ich weiß nicht so, auch der Zustand von so einem halbfertigen,
sich permanent für immer in Entwicklung befindlichen Game spricht mich jetzt nicht so an, aber
ich weiß, dass es genug Leute gibt, die spielen.
Spielt jemand von euch gerade?
Before we move on to our next story today, let us know what you think of Sony's comments
about Battlefield.
Do you think Battlefield...
Ich muss noch sagen, wo wir gerade bei Spielen sind, die nie fertig werden.
Star Citizen kannst du immerhin auch spielen und es scheint dir wohl auch genug Leute zu
geben, denen das gefällt.
Eine Sache muss ich jetzt mal sagen, ich habe ja früher ganz viel Dark Age of Camelot gespielt,
das war ein MMO aus 2001.
Das ist das Spiel bis mit heute, finde ich, das das beste MMO-PvP aller Zeiten hatte,
gerade weil du drei verschiedene Fraktionen hattest und so ist es halt nicht langweilig
geworden.
Es war dann nicht so nach dem Motto hier, eine Seite hat irgendwie 80% der Spieler wie
manche WoW-Server oder sowas, nee, das war eigentlich immer ganz gut.
So und vor ein paar Jahren hat der ehemalige Chef des Studios, die damals Dark Age of Camelot
gemacht haben, ein Nachfolger oder ein Alternativprodukt angekündigt, nämlich das hier.
So, das Spiel wurde angekündigt 2012 oder so und es gibt bis heute keine richtige Alpha
und keine richtige Beta, es gibt so interne Playtests und sowas und ich habe das damals
gebacked für glaube ich 200€ oder sowas für Early Access Zugang auf Kickstarter und worauf
ich raus will ist folgendes, ich habe mich selten so verarscht gefühlt wie von denen,
weil jetzt passt mal auf, ich hoffe man kann sich das anzeigen lassen, wir reden hier
von einem Spiel, das über 10 Jahre in Entwicklung ist und jetzt guckt euch mal den letzten Newsletter
an.
Concept Arts, wir reden über ein Spiel, was 10 Jahre in Entwicklung ist, Concept Arts,
sowas postet man in seinem Kickstarter Projekt um zu zeigen, guckt mal hier, so können wir
es uns vorstellen, Concept Arts, ok, ich meine diesmal sieht man da tatsächlich sogar ein
bisschen In-Game was, 10 Jahre, 10 Jahre Entwicklung, wo ist denn der letzte Newsletter, worüber
ich mich so lustig gemacht habe, jetzt einmal hier, Concept Arts, Concept Arts, so und im
letzten, in einem der anderen Newsletter, Concept Arts, Leute das Spiel ist 10-11 Jahre in Entwicklung
und wo sie den Vogel abgeschossen haben letztens, außer sie die Grafik für 10 Jahre immer noch
kann, wo sie wirklich den Vogel abgeschossen haben letztens war, haben sie den Newsletter
gepostet, so angeblich furchtbar neue Errungenschaften und da haben sie tatsächlich 3 Seiten drüber
geschrieben für ein Spiel, was über 10 Jahre in Entwicklung ist und am Ende haben sie 3
neue Bilder gepostet von Crafting-Werkzeugen, Crafting-Werkzeugen man und ich dachte mir
so Alter, das Spiel ist 10 Jahre in Entwicklung, was juckt mich wie eure scheiß Crafting-Werkzeuge
aussehen, warum sind die überhaupt noch nicht im Spiel drinnen nach 10 Jahren, also das
ist so heftig verkackt, also ich hab mir selten, ich kann mir selten so verarscht vor, von
einem Projekt als von Camelot Unchained, eine Sache wo ich mir nur ähnlich verarscht
vorkomme, immer ähnlich verarscht vorkam, war die Selbstreinigende Jeans, die ich auch
für 200-300€ gebacked habe, die aber niemals ausgeliefert wurde, alle Leute hier, selbstreinigende
Jeans, ich war so blöd, dass ich das geglaubt habe, selbstreinigende Jeans, aber die gibt
es bis heute nicht, Lieferung 2016, ja ist klar, ganz bestimmt, ich hab bis heute nichts
gekriegt, niemand hat bis heute irgendwas gekriegt, nach 5 Jahren, ist klar Flying Buttons, die
kommen jetzt bestimmt nach 5 Jahren zu dir und sagen ah, nee nach 6 Jahren, 6,5 Jahre,
kommen die bestimmt zu dir und sagen ah ja ja, ok jetzt gibt es einen Refund, ganz bestimmt,
Backweight, die haben mich richtig gescampt, man, benutzen immer noch die Dark Engine, nicht
direkt, also da muss man ein bisschen, letztendlich ist aber auch egal, ja aber ich versuche dir
das mal zu beantworten, also die Dark Engine war Gamebüro oder wie das hieß, irgendeine
alte Version davon oder Gamebrio, viele MMOs damals wurden darin erstellt, sogar Spiele
wie Fallout benutzen eine Variante davon, das war damals recht beliebt, dass es quasi
die Engine in der Dark auch entwickelt wurde und für Camelot Unchained wollten sie ja
eine eigene Engine bauen, die super massenschlachten und sowas kann, wobei sie unter der Haube
glaube ich tatsächlich auch wieder diesen Crap hier verwenden, deswegen sieht das Spiel
auch aus wie von 2014, ganz davon abgesehen das Spiel sieht ja aktuell auch gar nicht
aus, weil außer Concept Art gibt es ja nichts, kann man sowas bei Kickstarter melden, ja
aber Kickstarter kann ja da auch nicht viel machen, das Geld ist ja weitergeleitet worden
an die und es muss jedem klar sein, dass Kickstarter Risiko ist, also das einzige was sein kann
ist, wenn die vorsätzlich die Leute gescampt haben, dass es dann irgendeine Sammelklage
gibt, oftmals in den USA, falls irgendjemand dieses Desaster mit Chronicles of Illyria
oder wie das hieß mitbekommen hat, da ist ja auch so gelaufen, dass die gesagt haben
Alter die haben uns vorsätzlich gescampt, die haben millionenweise Geld eingesammelt
und hatten nie wirklich vor ein Spiel zu entwickeln, na dann gibt es vielleicht rechtlich Probleme,
aber ansonsten ist Kickstarter Risiko, ich meine wenn irgendjemand einsammelt, wenn jemand
50.000 Euro einsammelt und sagt er will davon Produkt XY bauen, er versucht es, er gibt
sich Mühe, es klappt nicht, aus welchen Gründen, er hat sich verkalkuliert, es ist gar nicht
möglich was auch immer, dann ist es letztendlich das Risiko, dass du da gebacked hast, das ist
halt Bestandteil der Plattform irgendwo und ich finde auch nicht, dass man jemanden sperren
sollte von Kickstarter, wenn er wirklich alles versucht hat das Projekt auf die Beine zu
stellen und es ist dann am Ende halt an irgendwelchen Sachen gescheitert, das kann ja sogar was
sein wo er es verkackt hat, wie gesagt er hat sich verkalkuliert mit der Zeit, mit was
es kostet, vielleicht fällt ihm erst beim Bauen auf, ok serienmäßig kann man sowas
gar nicht fertigen, was auch immer, das ist halt Risiko, das ist ja da nicht mutwillig
die Leute gescampt, die hatten ja wirklich vor das zu bauen, es gibt allerdings ein paar
Projekte wo ich mir auch denke, die sind von Anfang an eigentlich schon gar nicht möglich,
zum Beispiel gab es ja dieses Projekt, erinnert sich noch jemand an dieses Wasser in der Wüste
Projekte, wie war das, ich weiß gar nicht mehr wie das hieß, wie hieß denn dieses
ich war auch noch nie in einer Wüste, das war nicht auf Kickstarter, das war auf Indiegogo,
das gibt es gar nicht mehr ok, ach das ist jetzt was anderes oder, na zumindest die wollten
quasi in einer Wüste Trinkwasser für alle fördern und da hat man sich eigentlich von
Anfang an denken können, das kann nicht funktionieren, das ganze Konzept ergibt keinen Sinn und das
sind so Sachen wo ich mir dann denke, ey wer da backt weiß nicht, der will irgendwie gescampt
werden oder es gab doch auch mal dieses andere Projekt, da weiß ich aber gar nicht ob es
ein Kickstarter Projekt war oder ob das eines dieser super neuen Startups ist, es gab doch
mal dieses Karussellding mit dem besonders günstig Dinger in die Erdumlaufbahn geschossen
werden sollen, wie hieß das denn, die haben sich aufgespielt für das neue SpaceX, Spin
Launch, Chat wie ihr das wisst, Spin Launch genau, die meine ich, Spin Launch und das sind
auch so Dinger, die guckst du dir an und denkst dir so ok, ich frag mich allen Ernstes wie
soll das funktionieren, also denn ihre Idee ist folgendes, die, es gibt ja auf Niedermarkt
Schaltbilder, die wollen quasi so ein Karussell bauen und das soll gedreht werden und dann
soll das quasi so schnell gedreht werden, dass es dann in die Erdumlaufbahn geschossen
werden kann, also da gibt es so viele Probleme wo ich mir nicht vorstellen kann, dass es
funktioniert, also erstens ist halt Luftwiderstand immer noch ziemlich doof und das nächste
ist, wie unglaublich schnell sich der Kram drehen müsste, dass es das schnell genug
beschleunigen könnte, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das funktioniert, ich meine ich lass
mich da gerne eines besseren belehren, aber das sind so Dinger, wenn ich die sehe, habe
ich so meine Zweifel, ob das überhaupt funktionieren kann gescheit und mal davon abgesehen, warum
sollte man es drehen, warum nicht einfach mit irgendwelchen Magneten beschleunigen oder
sowas, also warum muss es sich gerade drehen, also da habe ich wirklich meine Zweifel,
ob das was ist, was funktionieren kann und da denke ich mir okay, wenn da jetzt einer
sein Geld rein haut, ist das dann noch Zukunftsvision oder ist das einfach Realität ausgeplendet?
Genau und du musst es auch noch richtig releasen, dass es dort hinkommt wo du es haben willst,
also ich habe echt große Zweifel, dass das realistisch ist.
Und hat der Test funktioniert?
Ja Moment, das funktioniert doch auch anders oder?
100 Kilo, na da viel Spaß, das funktioniert, ich habe da wirklich große Zweifel, ob das
tut, aber hey ich mein vielleicht bin ich einfach nur nicht zukunftsvisionär genug
dafür, aber gut es ist auch egal, es war kein Kickstarter Projekt, ich hab das durcheinander
gebracht.
Moment, Moment, es geht nicht darum irgendwas zu probieren, es geht darum was zu probieren,
was irgendwie realistisch erscheint und ich habe da meine Zweifel ob das realistisch ist,
es sagt jetzt ja auch keiner, guck mal es gibt genug Unternehmen die sagen wir bauen
einen Weltraumaufzug, gab es die letzten Jahre immer mal wieder und wer hat bisher einen
Weltraumaufzug gebaut?
Keiner, wir haben noch nicht mal Material um sinnvollerweise sowas zu bauen, geschweige
denn haben wir das Problem gelöst, wie weit musst du es auf der anderen Seite rausbauen
dass es funktioniert, nichtsdestotrotz hält es nicht Leute davon ab Unternehmen zu gründen
die angeblich einen Weltraumaufzug bauen wollen, macht es aber nicht realistischer, realistisch
ist zum Beispiel, dass wir mal wieder eine Mondbasis bauen oder sowas, das ist realistisch
da haben wir die Technologie dafür, das kostet Geld es fuck, das ist sicherlich nicht ungefährlich
das geht, aber es sind so ein paar andere Dinge wo ich mir denke ja ok, but why also das ist
total außerhalb der Möglichkeiten aktuell sowas zu bauen, das hat keiner gemacht, aber
es ist jetzt nicht so weit außerhalb der Vorstellungskraft dass man eine Rakete recycelbar bauen könnte
dass einer morgen in den nächsten paar Jahren irgendwie einen Weltraumaufzug baut, ist noch
mal ein ganz anderes Kaliber
Vor allem ist das Problem, dass du den ganzen Krempel auf der anderen Seite auch noch unglaublich
weit nach außen bauen müsstest und mit dem Material, was wir aktuell haben, müsstest
du das Ganze auch so kegelförmig bauen, das muss nach oben dann immer breiter werden
das war ganz merkwürdiges Zeug
46 Kilobyte, das hat er übrigens nie gesagt, dass 46 Kilobyte reichen
das ist auch so ein Zitat was ihm angedichtet wird
ja ne das hat er nie gesagt
noch eine weitere lustige Sache, Thema Weltraumaufzug, wisst ihr was da auch unglaublich schwierig
ist, also neben ganz den vielen anderen ungelösten Probleme, was da auch schwierig ist, die Stromversorgung
du kannst ja nicht einfach ein Kabel durchlegen, das wird schlicht und ergreifend alles zu
schwer und ist nicht belastbar genug, also du kannst ja nicht einfach Kabel durchlegen
ohne weiteres, oder ja gut, macht halt Probleme und das heißt das müsstest du dann mit einem
Laser machen oder sowas, sprich dass du dann einen super starken Laser auf der Erde hast
und an dem Fahrstuhl hast du dann quasi irgendwelche Foto Solar Panels quasi in klein, dann lasers
du dann da drauf und da gibt es wirklich enorm viele Probleme, aber es gibt trotzdem Unternehmen
die gegründet wurden die letzten Jahre, kommt immer mal wieder Neues dabei, die sagen sie
bauen sowas
es gibt enorm viele Probleme dazu, wie gesagt das ist halt so Sachen wo ich mir denke das
ist unrealistisch sowas in den nächsten paar Jahren oder Jahrzehnten zu bauen, da kann
man noch so viele tolle Marketing Ideen haben, es wird wahrscheinlich nichts, ja aber nicht
das was sie vorhaben, was anderes, da kommt vielleicht was bei raus ja, so also was kann
man uns als nächstes anschauen, zeig mal her, was haben wir denn hier für spannendes
Zeug, was ist das Spannend, Kecke, so das haben wir fertig geguckt, genug Level Captchi
Bait, ist Shepard am Ende nicht gestorben?
Ach keine Ahnung, ich blicke da nicht mehr durch, ok also was können wir uns als Akku
was haben wir hier zu bieten, 150 Euro, 150 Dollar, wahrscheinlich eher 200 Euro nass,
you can actually build, naja das ist kein Ding nass für 150 Dollar oder für 150 Euro
zu bauen, da kann ich auch was zusammenwursten, ohne Platten versteht sich, ob man das dann
wirklich betreiben will, das stimmt schon, ist was anderes, wir skippen mal kurz drüber,
was denkst du Elon Musk wird in 10 bis 20 Jahren US Präsident werden, weiß gar nicht
ob er da Interesse dran hat, genug Hardcore Fans hätte er wahrscheinlich, ich weiß halt
nicht ob es dafür in der Summe genug gibt, ach der ist kein Ami, ist er nicht, echt nicht,
ja dann wird das nichts, du musst ja, soweit ich weiß, musst du ja nicht nur Amerikaner
sein, du musst auch auf dem Festland geboren sein, nee dann wird das nichts, dann kannst
du es vergessen, wie gesagt du musst glaube ich auf dem Festland geboren sein, es gibt
da irgendwelche komischen Regelungen, wie du nur wann du US Präsident werden darfst,
ja dann wird das natürlich nichts, ich wusste gar nicht, dass der Südafrikaner ist, wenn
es danach geht bin ich ja auch halber, nee Viertel Südafrikaner, mein Uropa war in Südafrika,
es war ja wohl damals so eine beliebte Fluchtort für Deutsche Südafrika, ja liegt, es war damals
glaube ich tatsächlich relativ häufig, dass Leute so geflüchtet sind nach Südafrika,
also was heißt geflüchtet, also von meinem Uropa weiß ich nur, das war irgendwie so,
dass seine Frau hier, also quasi meine Uroma, die war schwanger mit meiner Oma und dann
ist mein Uropa abgehauen, als die schwanger war nach Südafrika, einfach CU, nix wie weg,
fuck, Verantwortung, Verpflichtung hier, ich muss weg und dann ist er nach Südafrika abgehauen,
xD, Dankeschön für den Sub, ich hoffe ich hab nichts übersehen an Subscriptions hier,
einfach CU, ja, einfach weg, gut mehr weiß ich dazu nix, nee mein Uropa das war noch
vor zweitem Weltkrieg und sonst was, ne ganze Weile vor zweitem Weltkrieg müsste das gewesen
sein, ich weiß noch nicht mal ob's, lasst mal überlegen, ich kann's euch nicht genau
sagen aber wir können das mal kurz überschlagen, also, ich bin 38, so, meine Mutter hat mich
auch ungefähr gekriegt so mit 35, ok, sagen wir mal mit 40, 40, 80 Jahre, die Oma hat
sie auch wegen Krieg und allem relativ spät gekriegt, also hauen wir da nochmal 35 Jahre
drauf, also rechnen wir mal hoch 120 Jahre und dann noch der Uropa, das müsste jetzt
quasi so vor 150 Jahren gewesen sein, ungefähr, würde ich jetzt mal so sagen, so in dem Dreh,
vor 150 Jahren, also 2022 minus 150, 1872, kann das sein, das kommt einem ja so ewig
lang her man, ja aber das kann schon sein, das ist 1872, oder sag mal, gut, der Uropa
hat ja auch vielleicht wahrscheinlich nicht zwei Jahre nach Geburt bekommen, sag mal so
vielleicht, vielleicht 1900, vielleicht 1900, zumindest ist man nur Uropa abgehauen, General
Slay, dankeschön für den Sub, also, wie gesagt, ich kann es jetzt natürlich nur raten, also
ich denke mal, irgendwie so zwischen 1870 und 1910 oder so wird das gewesen sein, keine
Ahnung, also es müsste auf jeden Fall noch vor dem ersten Weltkrieg gewesen sein und
es müsste auch weit, weit vom zweiten Weltkrieg gewesen sein, 1900 wahrscheinlich, ja also
in dem Dreh, ah, siehst du, da ist er abgehauen nach Südafrika, man hat nie wieder was von
ihm gehört, soweit die Überlieferung zu meinem Uropa, ja, keine Ahnung, was da wirklich
war, ich meine, ich war ja logischerweise nicht dabei, okay, also weiter, da gibt es
bestimmt noch Grundbesitz in Südafrika, der jetzt mir gehört, hey, vielleicht, wer weiß,
vielleicht bin ich mit Elon Musk verwandt, kann alles sein, okay, also was baut er denn
hier für nass zusammen, wir gucken das jetzt nochmal ganz, durchgeskippt, also, oder, okay,
das ist ja logisch, die Festplatten kannst du in dem Preis nicht inkluden, Festplatte
allein kostet ja schon 150 Euro, also eine große, ja, er hat von Ebay eine alte Kiste
gekauft, ja super, Leute, Wade, was ist das, ist das der Passwort Save von NordVPN, Leute,
ich vertraue ja NordVPN noch nicht mal, dass sie ein ordentlicher VPN Service sind, ich
würde im Leben, im Traum, was gibt es da noch für eine Steigerung von, also niemals
im Leben, nicht mal im Traum, würde mir einfallen, meine Passwörter im NordVPN Passwort Save
zu speichern, in keiner Dimension des Multiversums würde es mir einfallen, meine Passwörter
im NordVPN Passwort Save zu speichern, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,
ja, klar.
Okay erzähl mal also er hat einen alten Rechner von Ebay gekauft, ein Zeug eingebaut.
Na geil!
Uldrastar Hitachi!
Ist doch, oder?
Ist doch Hitachi.
Ganze 4TB, oh das geht doch sogar.
Okay, use this.
Hey, das ist Dings hier.
Ach ne, das ist Open...
Aha!
Das neue Open Media Vault habe ich noch gar nicht gesehen.
Das sieht ja tatsächlich ganz brauchbar aus mittlerweile.
Ah, Runde, Runde, Wärmeleitpass drauf spritzen.
Leute, ihr müsst mir jetzt mal, wo wir gerade dabei sind, ich bin ja dabei mir einen neuen
Rechner zusammenzustellen.
Und ich habe mehr oder weniger alles schon soweit mir ausgesucht, aber ich bin immer
noch ein bisschen am überlegen, ob, also da hängt auch ein bisschen davon ab, welches
Gehäuse es am Ende wird, ob Luft- oder Wasserkühlung.
Ich hätte ja mal Bock, wirklich mal einen Rechner mit Wasserkühlung zu bauen.
Ich meine, das wird irgendeine All-in-one-Wasserkühlung, nix custom gewurstet das, ja klar, für Noobs
wie mich.
Aber, die Sache ist halt die, das wird entweder ein 13900 oder ein 13700, nimmt sich ja nicht
allzu viel.
Ist Wasserkühlung eigentlich wartungsfrei, wenn du so eine All-in-one nimmst?
Ja, wobei ich da nicht weiß, ich hatte sowas ja noch nie.
Wobei ich nicht weiß, ob man nicht dort auch irgendwie alle paar Jahre was wechseln muss
oder so.
Hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert, weiß ich nicht.
Die Pumpe ist viel zu laut, sagst du das jetzt nur oder hast du das ausprobiert, weil ich
hab paar Tests gelesen, zum Beispiel für diese Arctic Cooling Freezer 2 oder so, die
sind eigentlich relativ leise laut Tests, ja, das hab ich auch gelesen und da ist halt
das, weißt du das, weil du es selbst hattest oder sagst du das jetzt nur, weil du es in
einem Forum gelesen hast.
Ich hab beispielsweise einen Langzeit-Test gelesen, da haben sie glaube ich 8 Jahre
oder so die Wasserkühlung verbaut gehabt und die ging danach immer noch ganz gut und
es gibt sogar Hersteller, die geben dir mittlerweile 5 Jahre Garantie auf ihre Wasserkühlung,
das heißt es wäre ziemlich bescheuert, wenn ihr nach 3-4 Jahren kaputt geht, weil, also
warum ich überhaupt am überlegen bin ist folgendes, warum ich am überlegen bin ist
folgendes, also wir testen Deutschlands beliebteste Wasserkühlung, welche ist denn das, ist das
deutschland beliebteste Wasserkühlung, ach hier da ist das Ding, ok das können wir uns
tatsächlich gleich mal angucken, also die Sache ist halt die, wie gesagt entweder 13.900
oder 13.700, die Sache ist halt die, wenn man da jetzt nach, wenn man da mit Benchmarks
machen will, ja, also wenn ich da irgendwie Signbench, Scenebench, Primeforma 95 geduldens
Volllast laufen lassen will, dann kommen die CPUs quasi immer auch mit einer Wasserkühlung
ans 100 Grad Limit, die Sache ist nur die, dass das unter realistischen Bedingungen,
also bei Spielen zum Beispiel oder auch bei Video editieren und selbst bei Video rendern
so nicht sein wird, das heißt aus dem Gesichtspunkt reicht eine Luftkühlung eigentlich aus, es
sei denn, also es kommt auch ein bisschen drauf an, was für ein Powerlimit man im BIOS
einstellt, es sei denn man legt Wert auf irgendwie besonders hohen Boosttakt, weil das macht
die CPU ja irgendwie daran fest, wie viel Temperaturspielraum sie noch hat, also es
könnte sein, dass potenziell die CPU kühler bleibt mit einer Wasserkühlung und dementsprechend
länger schneller hochtakten kann, ich weiß halt nicht, ob sich der ganze Stress, den man
eventuell hat durch eine Wasserkühlung, lohnt versus eine Luftkühlung, Luftkühlung wäre
ganz einfach, da haue ich weder Noctua DH15 oder NH12 oder wie das kleinere heißt drauf
und gut ist, ich habe eine umfunktionierte Abstellkammer, das ist richtig, theoretisch
könnte ich mein PC da reinstellen, will ich aber nicht, mal ganz davon abgesehen, die
hat ja keine Klimaanlage, für alles was da aktuell drin ist, ist es kein Problem, aber
wenn ich da meinen Rechner rein haue, dann wird es zu warm, ich meine die CPU frisst
bis zu 300 Watt, die Grafikkarte auch, was auch immer wie viel, das wird nix, machst
du PC Building Stream, ja mache ich, wenn ich mich dann endlich mal dafür entschieden
habe, was ich kaufe, du kriegst die Wasserkühlung nicht in ein kleines Case, da brauchst du
mindestens 360 mm oder 420 mm, also brauchst du eine große Wasserkühlung und dementsprechend
brauchst du auch ein sehr fettes Case, du brauchst aber eh ein fettes Case, weil du
eine 4090 einbauen musst, was sagt der Bauer dazu, der kennt sich mit sowas doch aus, Deutschlands
beliebteste Wasserkühlung, warum kein 13600, weil ich Performance High End kaufen will,
das muss ja mit der 5er halten, Visa 2, das ist auch die günstigste AIO, die wir im Test
haben, kostet ca. 115 Euro aktuell für eine 360 AIO, echt sehr sehr preiswert muss man
sagen, von der Montage ist es auf jeden Fall anders als die anderen im Test, hier haben
wir erstmal links und rechts diese zwei schwarzen Brackets, die wir unten am Pumpenkopf befestigen
müssen, abhängig davon welcher Sockel verwendet wird, dann haben wir hier die Backplate, da
kommen Abstandshalter durch, die Abstandshalter werden mit O-Ringen von oben gesichert, das
ganze kommt dann von unten durchs Mainboard und dann klebt man normalerweise diese Mini
Unterlegscheiben um die Sockelmontagelöcher außen rum, ich persönlich klebe das immer
ganz gern auf die Seite von dem Abstandshalter, weil dann habe ich es nicht auf dem Mainboard
kleben, wenn ich dann was anderes montieren möchte, dann schraubt man das hier rein,
anschließend noch den Pumpenkopf drauf und dann mit den Schrauben hier fixieren.
Interessanterweise holt sich Arctic Liquid Freezer 2360 erstmal die Spitze im Gaming
Test mit 38,5 Grad Celsius, wenn wir allerdings auf Volllast gehen, dann sehen wir, dass
die Lüfter einfach nicht genug Drehzahl haben, um mit den anderen AIOs mithalten zu können,
dafür ist das Ding aber wirklich angenehm leise, also mit maximaler Drehzahl 42,6 dB,
da haben wir mit den anderen ja 10 mehr, das ist schon echt ein großer Unterschied, dafür
ist es sehr sehr nah an der Silent Loop 2 dran.
Die sehr gute L-
Also 42 dB ist nicht viel, es ist aber hörbar auf jeden Fall, ja, also 42 dB ist ungefähr
so ASMR-Videolautstärke, trifft es glaube ich ganz gut, wenn einer so hörbar flüstert
würde ich sagen, sind ungefähr 42, guck mal mal, ja, ja, genau, Soft Whisper, ok, 42
ist so ein bisschen mehr, dB ist ja so eine etwas unintuitive Skalierung, also man darf
jetzt nicht davon ausgehen, dass 80 dB doppelt so laut sind wie 40, sondern die sind viel
viel viel viel viel lauter als 40, ich glaube alle, so ungefähr alle drei dB das doppelte
oder wie war das, ich krieg's aus dem Kopf, ich glaube mit einem Daumen gepeilt kann man
irgendwie sagen alle drei doppelt so laut oder ne, wie ist das, ich krieg's aus dem
Kopf nicht mal hin, ne alle 13, alle 13 doppelt so laut, ach keine Ahnung, weiß nicht, ob
alle 5 oder 10, alle 10, wisst ihr, Chet hat auch keine Ahnung, genauso wie ich, also das
dürfte, das dürfte ungefähr, wenn ihr ASMR-Videos hört, ungefähr in dieser Lautstärke dürfte
dann auch euren, na gut, das hängt natürlich davon ab wie weit ihr euch aufreißt, also
wenn einer flüstert, das hört man, also wenn einer hörbar, also wenn einer flüstert,
so dass er will, dass er verstanden wird, also es ist auf jeden Fall hörbar, ja, wie war
das jetzt hier mit der Lautstärke, wie war das mit der Lautstärke, also 42, 42, also
man hört's auf jeden Fall und man hört's halt immer, auch im Desktopbetrieb, das Gute
aktuell an meinem Setup ist halt, da ist zwar ein fetter Noctua-Lüfter drauf und wenn ich
spiele, dann dreht der auch ein bisschen rauf, aber im Desktopbetrieb hör ich mein Rechner
halt gar nicht, ich höre gerade, du hörst nichts, der ist quasi silent, der Noctua dreht
ganz leise, die Gehäuse-Lüfter drehen ganz leise, also langsam und leise, ich höre aktuell
quasi nichts.
Der Silent Loop 2 dran, die sehr gute Leistung erkauft sich die Liquid Freezer 2 AIO vor allem
durch die Dicke des Radiators, wir haben hier 35mm, während wir bei den meisten anderen
AIOs nur 25mm Dicke haben und dementsprechend haben wir hier einfach deutlich mehr Fläche.
Wir machen weiter mit der Pure Loop 2FX, wieder von Be Quiet, auf den ersten Blick könnte
man meinen, dass es ein bisschen ähnlich zu Silent...
Im Gaming-Szenario ist die Arctic Liquid Freezer 2 AIO auf jeden Fall der Gewinner, die Temperaturen
überzeugen und der Preis ist mit 115€ einfach unschlagbar, allerdings müssen wir hier
auch erwähnen, dass durch den dickeren Radiator die AIO auch mal mit dem Gehäuse kollidieren
kann, wenn ihr da was kleines oder enges habt, das müsst ihr auf jeden Fall vorher...
Ich brauche jedenfalls das Gehäuse.
Deepcool LS720 ist aus meiner Sicht aber auch auf jeden Fall eine Empfehlung wert, denn
sie ist am Ende nur minimal schlechter als die Arctic Liquid Freezer 2 im Gaming-Szenario,
hat aber zusätzlich RGB-Lüfter und aus meiner Sicht auch den...
Wichtig, wichtig, wichtig.
...deutlich ansprechendem Pumpen- bzw. Kühlerkopf und kostet dafür auch nur 30€ mehr.
Die Be Quiet Silent Doop 2 und NZXT Kraken bieten für den Preis ebenfalls eine sehr solide
Leistung und sind optisch für mich subjektiv betrachtet auch schöne Alternativen zum Liquid
Freezer 2.
Bei den Be Quiet AIOs sei zusätzlich noch positiv erwähnt, dass diese die einzigen
Modelle im Test waren, die einen vernickelnden Boden haben, damit rein theoretisch auch kompatibel
zu Flüssigmetall sind und definitiv korrosionsbeständiger.
Oh, also was ich definitiv nicht mehr machen werde ist meine CPU-Köpfen, das habe ich
mit meinem aktuellen gemacht, da habe ich geschwitzt, so wie selten beim Basteln mit
Technik.
Also ich habe ja aktuell 8700k, ist schon ein bisschen her, ist schon ein bisschen älter
und ich hatte einen der ersten, ich bin an einen der ersten CPUs in Deutschland gekommen
damals.
Also ich habe die ganz normal bezahlt, ich habe die nicht irgendwie gesponsert bekommen,
aber die haben das natürlich noch früher gehabt, aber ich hatte quasi eine der ersten
normal lieferbaren CPUs in Deutschland, das heißt hätte ich die kaputt gemacht beim
Köpfen, ich hätte 4-5 Wochen warten müssen, bis ich überhaupt wieder eine CPU bekommen
hätte.
Ich habe wirklich geschwitzt damals und außerdem wären es auch irgendwie 450€ gewesen,
wenn ich den Sand gesetzt hätte.
Ich habe wirklich geschwitzt beim Köpfen, glaubt's mir, Alter.
CPU, ich habe das sogar aufgenommen, ich wollte das damals ein Video zu machen, aber
das hat mir qualitativ da nicht gefallen, das habe ich auf einen blöden Winkel aufgenommen.
Also das war wirklich nicht ohne.
Wenn man den Preis betrachtet, ergeben MSI Core Liquid, Aorus Waterforce und Corsair H150E
Capellix auf jeden Fall wenig Sinn.
Dafür bieten diese extra Features wie LCD Display, IQ Integration oder generell Möglichkeiten,
euer System an gegebenenfalls vorhandene Komponenten anzupassen, sei das jetzt z.B.
die M-Bot, die Giga, die D-Bot.
Ich meine, sieht cool aus, brauchen tut's keiner, wer guckt da schon rein?
Bei MSI das entsprechende Mainboard oder auch bei Gigabyte das entsprechende Mainboard oder
Grafikkarte.
Die Ergebnisse hier unter Volllast zeigen jetzt noch auf, welches Kühlungspotential
in den Lüften…
Ja, ok, unter Volllast, wie laut sind die im Desktopbetrieb?
Das ist ja das, was mich interessiert.
Weil, ganz im Ernst, 42 dBm…
Ah ne, Moment, Moment.
Das ist jetzt unter…
Ha, ich hab mich verguckt.
Das ist ja nix, da hast du ehn Kopfhörer auf
Und selbst wenn, denn stört dich das nicht
Wie hast du den geköpft mit dem Tool vom Bauer? Ne, mit nem Konkurrenz-Tool
Ich wollte mir ursprünglich eigentlich das Tool vom Bauer kaufen
Aber das war damals nicht lieferbar, da hab ich, was hab ich denn, Doktor Delid
CPU hieß das glaube ich
So ein Ding, so ein Ding hab ich mir damals gekauft, hab ich letztens erst weggeschmissen, braucht man ja nicht mehr
Painless and easy, so ein Teil hatte ich damals
Hab ich letztens erst entsorgt
Und dann, und dann Flüssigmetall, drunter
Direkt auf die CPU. War es painless und easy?
Im Prinzip ja, war es. Ich hab halt übelst geschwitzt dabei, weil du halt bei jedem Knacken und so gedacht hast, du machst deine CPU kaputt
Also ich kann euch sagen, es ist ein ganz komisches Gefühl
Wenn ihr an eurer CPU rumschaut, dann ist das ein ganz komisches Gefühl
Ein ganz komisches Gefühl, wenn ihr an eurer CPU rumschraubt und es macht Knackgeräusche, dann denkt ihr erstmal, fuck das geht kaputt, aber das ist normal
Das ist normal, weil
Das ist ja festgeklebt
Das reißt halt ab und dann macht, dann macht es immer
Was genau bringt das Köpfen der CPU? Also prinzipiell erst einmal gar nichts, also nicht einfach machen, weil ich jetzt irgendwie was gesagt hab
Das war in Zeiten, wo Intel gespart hat bei den CPUs. Der 8700K
Der hatte Zwischenmoment
Mal gucken, ob es da ein Bild irgendwie von gibt
Also normalerweise machst du deinen Lüfter ja hier oben drauf
Ja, ja hier sieht man es, hier sieht man es schön, also normalerweise ist, das hier ist ja normalerweise der Deckel
Von deiner CPU
Ist quasi so der Heatspreader für den, für den, für den Kühler, da kommt, da kommt obendrauf kommt ein CPU Kühler drauf
So, Intel hat jetzt gespart, Intel hat es nämlich hier folgendermaßen gemacht
Das hier ist ja quasi die, die, die Oberseite von der, von der, von der Lüftung
Das hier ist ja quasi die, die, die Oberseite von der, von der CPU, also wenn du hier was kaputt machst, ist deine CPU im Arsch
Die hat die Oberseite der CPU und den Heatspreader nur mit Wärmeleitpaste miteinander verklebt
Also intern in der CPU selber, also in diesem, in diesem kompletten Paket da
War das dann hier Wärmeleitpaste drauf und die war dann halt hier oben mit
verpappt, ja
Das heißt, du hast quasi intern von der CPU
die Hitze
eh schon nur über Wärmeleitpaste an den Heatspreader weitergegeben und von dort dann noch mal Wärmeleitpaste an den Kühlkörper und dann ging es weiter
so
Wenn man diesen Heatspreader entfernt hat
Hier sieht man ja auch wie es funktioniert, ja, ja, ist gut
Wenn man den Heatspreader entfernt hat, dann kann man direkt an die Oberseite von der CPU dran, dann hat man dort so
Flüssigmetall Legierungen drauf gemacht und dann musste man aufpassen, Obacht
Entweder haben ganz verrückte Leute direkt hier drauf ihren Kühlkörper gemacht
Da musste man aber aufpassen, dass du es auf gar keinen Fall verkanntest, weil ansonsten ist deine CPU kaputt
Oder was ich gemacht habe
Ich habe hier Flüssigmetall dazwischen gemacht
Ab den Heatspreader wieder oben drauf gemacht, also was ich im Prinzip gemacht habe ist
Ich habe die billige Wärmeleitpaste, die Intel hier dazwischen hatte, ausgetauscht durch Flüssigmetall Legierungen
Was deutlich besser die Wärme geleitet hat oder leitet zwischen der CPU und dem Heatspreader und dann da oben drauf den Kühler
Hat den Vorteil, du machst nicht so leicht was kaputt
Wenn du direkt hier drauf den Kühler machst, gerade wenn es auch Kupfer unten hat, Kupfer hat Probleme oftmals mit der Legierung
Dass es dann anfängt
Bröselig zu werden mit den Jahren
Kühlt theoretisch noch ein bisschen besser, aber ist auch viel größer die Chance, dass du deine CPU kaputt machst
So und das sah dann folgendermaßen aus
Ja genau, dann sieht man es, das hier ist der Heatspreader oben drauf und dazwischen hat Intel Wärmeleitpaste gemacht
So, damals, wohlgemerkt bei aktuellen CPUs
Bei aktuellen CPUs ist das verlötet
Glaube ich zumindest, also man muss das nicht mehr köpfen aktuell
Hier dazwischen ist keine Wärmeleitpaste mehr bei neuen CPUs, sondern das ist verlötet, das ist also alles gut
So, mal gucken, ob es zeigt, wie das geht. Ja, genau
Ich hoffe, man bekommt den Sound der knackenden CPU mit
Nein, die haben keinen Sound mit aufgenommen
Die haben keinen Sound mit aufgenommen
Nein, die haben keinen Sound mit aufgenommen, Leute
Hier, eure CPU knarzt und knackt und ihr denkt euch gleich ist sie kaputt
Jetzt, die macht normalerweise so
Und dann ist sie halt offen und du denkst dir halt, oh jetzt habe ich sie kaputt gemacht
Ja, das ab, das ab
So einfach ab geht das auch nicht
Zumindest bei mir nicht, ich musste hier unten drunter noch ab, also ich musste noch ein bisschen, ein bisschen nachhelfen, dass das abgeht
Das war jetzt eine ziemliche, ziemliche
Blödsinnige Anleitung, ich meine, die haben zwei Sekunden das eigentliche Köpfen der CPU gezeigt
Also damals war das sinnvoll und es hat wirklich enorm, Leute, das hat wirklich extrem viel gebracht
Meine CPU ist danach irgendwie 12, 13 Grad kühler gewesen als vorher
Also es war ein richtig, es war wirklich, oder 15 Grad, es war ein riesen Unterschied
Vorher Prime 95 direkt ans Limit geschossen
Danach konnte ich ihn übertacken 400 Megahertz auf glaube 5,2
5,2 Gigahertz in 8700K und er lief immer noch mit Luftkühlung
Also das hat wirklich extrem viel gebracht
Bei hoher Drehzahl steckt
Ich muss auch erwähnen, dass bei den kompletten Tests, sei das jetzt Gaming oder auch bei diesen Tests, die Pumpen immer bei 100% liefen
Das könnt ihr euch jetzt noch helfen, je nachdem, wofür ihr eure IEO
Wenn es unter Volllast 42 dB ist, dann ist das eigentlich okay
Das ist nicht irgendwie belastend, das ist leises Flüstergeräusch während man spielt, ist doch überhaupt kein Problem
Also ich tendiere aktuell nämlich tatsächlich eher zur Wasserkühlung
Einfach weil ich schon immer mal eine Weiz-PC mit Wasserkühlung jetzt haben wollte
Ich meine die ganze Zeit habe ich ja immer gesagt, gehen wir fort mit Wasserkühlung
...auswählen möchtet, beziehungsweise wofür ihr das einfach braucht
Wenn zwischendurch kleine Bench Sessions auch mal geplant sind, dann würde ich persönlich zur Kraken X73, Corsair H150i oder Deepcool LS720 greifen
Einfach weil die Kühlleistung oben hin auch noch da ist und das Mounting entsprechend einfach ist, um auch mal entspannt die CPU zu wechseln
Fairerweise muss man aber trotzdem sagen, dass die Arctic Liquid Freezer 2 hier auch wieder eine Art Gewinner für sich ist
Zwar jetzt nicht durch die niedrigsten Temperaturen, aber wenn man jetzt mal die Temperaturen betrachtet
In dazu in Relation die Lüftergeschwindigkeit und damit auch die Lautstärke, da muss ich sagen, spricht es schon für sich
Abzuraten wäre aus meiner Sicht hier von der Pure Loop 2 FX 360 von Be Quiet
Ich will keine Custom-Wasserkühlung, ich will irgendwas, was ich mir komplett selber bauen kann
Also wo ich meinen Rechner selbst zusammenbauen kann und fertig
In unserem Test, die die CPU bei Full-Out, also mit 260 Watt, nicht dauerhaft kühlen konnte
Also hier war es so, dass die CPU auf manchen Kerlen so heiß wurde, dass es sich runtertakten musste
Insgesamt würde ich sagen, dass gerade die Gigabyte Waterforce 360 und die MSI Core Liquid 360
Das gilt wahrscheinlich auch für eine Asus AIO, die ich jetzt nicht im Test hatte
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich persönlich sagen würde, die würde ich jetzt unbedingt verwenden
Ich sehe, dass man die eigentlich nur verwendet, wenn man ein System hat, wo das vom Theme her irgendwie reinpassen soll
Ansonsten gerade preisleistungstechnisch
Also ganz ehrlich, ob das einheitlich aussieht oder so in meinem Rechner ist mir vollkommen egal
Die AIOs von diesen Herstellern wahrscheinlich immer die schlechtesten
An der Stelle muss ich auch einmal sagen, Gigabyte, ihr müsst endlich mal eure RGB-Software in den Griff kriegen
Das ist wirklich absolut grausam
Also die anderen machen jetzt auch nicht die beste Software, aber aus meiner Sicht
Gigabyte immer mit Abstand am schlechtesten bei der RGB-Software geht einfach, es geht einfach auf die Nerven
Also ich sehe halt auch irgendwie keine Entwicklung bei Gigabyte in der Software
Und da muss echt mal endlich mal was passieren
Dieses Video war jetzt vom Zeitaufwand her sowieso viel mehr, als ich dachte
Ich habe jetzt deswegen nur eine einzelne AIO und da habe ich mir jetzt die Gigabyte AIO ausgesucht
Weil die überraschenderweise, sage ich mal, schlecht performt hat und die sollte wahrscheinlich eigentlich besser sein
Und ich habe das jetzt mal mit dem Contact Frame von Thermal Grizzly, also von uns montiert und da sehen wir
Was zum Teufel ist ein Contact Frame?
Ich dachte dort ist alles dabei, was man braucht, um es zu montieren auf der, auf der CPU
Ah, ich weiß was es ist, doch, jetzt wo ich nachdenke, das ist so ein Teil, dass der Druck, dass der, dass der Anpressdruck gleichmäßiger auf dem Mainboard verteilt ist oder sowas, gell
Das ist so quasi, da kannst du dann quasi dein Drumme rum, wo du normalerweise den Lüfter reinklipst, kannst du austauschen durch irgendwas, wo du ein bisschen mehr Druck auf die CPU kriegst
Glaube ich, sowas ist das glaube ich, sowas ist das glaube ich
Verbesserung von 5,5 Grad
Jetzt ist es natürlich so, dass wahrscheinlich auch andere, wahrscheinlich die meisten von den AIOs auch eine Verbesserung sehen würden
Also man sieht auf jeden Fall nochmal einen Shift nach links, etwas niedrigere Temperaturen, da kann man nochmal was rausholen
Es ist jetzt für mich vom Zeitaufwand her einfach zu viel jetzt nochmal jede AIO da einzubauen, nochmal jede mit einem Contact Frame und dann zu checken, was da verbesserungsmäßig drin ist
Aber es sei auf jeden Fall erwähnt, dass auf jeden Fall diese Plattform nicht gerade positiv für diverse Kühler ist, was die Kühlleistung betrifft
Ansonsten muss man auch ganz klar festhalten, dass es eigentlich egal ist, welche wir hier verwenden
Wenn ihr das nur zum zocken verwendet, ist es komplett egal, weil guckt euch die Temperaturen an, die wir bei dem 12900KS hatten
Wir reden da um Temperaturen im Schnitt, wie gesagt im Schnitt ist auch wichtig zu sagen, von 40 Grad Celsius
Da auch wichtig, wir haben ja den Durchschnitt über alle Kerne gebildet, das heißt alle 8 P-Cores, alle 8 E-Cores
Bedeutet natürlich auch, dass da gerne mal ein P-Core dabei ist, der dann seine 60-70 Grad hat und wird natürlich im Durchschnitt dann von den anderen Kernen runtergezogen
Aber trotzdem sind es Temperaturen, die halt absolut traumhaft sind für alle CPUs in dieser Region, also zum zocken
Komplett egal, welche ihr da benutzt, könnt ihr eigentlich frei auswählen, weil es ist eurer CPU einfach egal, ob die jetzt da 5-6 Grad kühler läuft
Ich glaube, ich hole mir dieses mal wirklich eine Wasserkühlung, ich hab da irgendwie mal Bock
Und der Rechner wird eh teuer als fuck
Da kann man sich das, kann man das mal machen
Zu betrachten, und noch mal der Hinweis, auch wenn wir jetzt für dieses Video das...
Ist, ist, ist Twitch, was, ist Twitch am abkacken?
Sekunde, stats, oh!
Vodafone! Was ist hier los? Was ist hier los, Vodafone?
Was gibt es hier? Anzeige ist raus
Nein, Gott! Nein, Gott, bitte nein! Nein! Nein! Nein!
Ganz übersehen
Ja, was machen wir denn da jetzt, wenn Vodafone wieder am rumkacken ist hier, was ist das?
Guckt euch das mal an, 65% Framedrops
What the fuck, Vodafone, please
Ich mach mal kurz den Speedtest auf der anderen Seite, mal kurz gucken, was da wieder, was da wieder hier im Argen ist
Da geht gar nichts, wenn man das Speedtest funktioniert richtig
Vodafone war wieder richtig am reinscheißen grad
Nicht mal, nicht mal der Speedtest funktioniert, man
Speedtest ist broken
Na toll, erstklassig, funktioniert ja wieder alles
Einfach 65% weniger Framedrops, high IQ Chat wieder
Dann sind es halt nur 65% von weniger
Der Speedtest, der geht einfach nicht, also Vodafone ist komplett im Arsch gerade
Ok, jetzt wird es ein bisschen besser, zeigt mal
No Pass
55 prozent
Aus geht runter leute es geht runter
Wir sind wir sind bloß noch bei wir sind bloß noch bei 17 prozent 20 prozent frame loss
Jetzt geht der speed test auch wieder auf der anderen seite okay, okay?
Leute was soll ich machen man könnte versuchen den twitch server zu wechseln aber ich ich
vermute daran liegt es nicht
Ja die haben auch eine all in one wasserkühlung verbauen sollen auf ihren twitchen
okay okay okay okay oh leute leute postchamp postchamp
postchamp
Schein wieder zu gehen
Guckt mal da geht wieder easy
geht wieder hoffen wir mal das bleibt so
Okay nice nice nice nice funktioniert wieder sehr schön
Also was können wir uns als nächstes mal anschauen was haben wir hier nass
ja das sind verstehen geblieben das hat ja überhaupt keinen sinn gemacht dieses bild
bild von ihm also was heißt keinen sinn gemacht würde ich nicht bauen
Was ist das egg drop from space führt das auf trending boah da haben wir mal hier richtiges
hype und ja richtig richtiges hype und angesagtes video erwischt
egg drop from space warum aber sonst noch overwatch 2 ist erbärmlich
okay jetzt gehts los super base in 100 sekunden pokemon kamezin und pupe sind eine technische
katastrophe ach komm wir gucken das jetzt an mal gucken mal gucken was das was das egg
macht wenn es from space droppt
Schauen wir mal wo davon okay ne schein wieder alles zu funktionieren
excellent okay gucken wir uns mal an das das das egg drop from space
habt ihr in der schule eine egg drop competition gemacht also das ist mir neu so was haben
wir nicht haben wir nicht versucht
also weißt du wisst ihr wisst ihr was ich mir über also was mir so spontan einfallen
würde was glaube ich wirklich ganz gut funktionieren müsste einen großen ball nehmen so ein ball
wie man zum beispiel im schwimmbad nimmt
diese aufblasbaren zum aufblasen zum aufblasen mein chat overlay ist 5 minuten zurück wirklich
kann überhaupt nicht sein das steht da drinnen ne das ist du musst refreshen das ist aktuell
also bei mir ja so ein ball guckt mal so ein ball müsste man nehmen so sowas hier so ein
aufblasbaren ball also das ist das erste was mir so spontan einfällt ja so ein aufblasbaren
ball und da das da das ei irgendwie in die mitte in die mitte hängen also müsste dann
da innen drinnen er müsste das halt irgendwie aufmachen und das ei irgendwie ein paar gummys
in die mitte hängen das ist das das ist das erste was mir spontan
einfallen würde so ein so ein dann kann man das wahrscheinlich von relativ hoch droppen
ohne dass was passiert man das ganz jetzt noch mit helium füllt oder so dann fällt es noch
langsamer ok auf gehts also es passt ein t-shirt für abend der würde platzen im weltall
axe that rocket to a weather balloon and take it up the space once there the weather balloon
would release it and just by using gravity only the rocker would eventually accelerate
pass mark one breaking the speed of sound and then it would autonomously adjusts the four
fins on the back to steer itself to the target location and then at 300 feet above the ground
it will release the egg which would free fall onto a mattress that we'd placed on the ground
Und das war ziemlich einfach.
So wie alle guten Ingenieuren würden, haben wir das Problem in kleineren Schritten gebrochen.
Das könnte ich mir vorstellen, das könnte schon funktionieren.
Im Vakuum wäre das deutlich besser.
Weil da fällt alles gleich schnell.
Alter, dass das das Ei aushält, hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Kommt mal hier mit was für einem Ding, mit was für einer Power, die das dagegen dondert.
Aha.
Moment mal, ich muss mir kurz angucken, was haben wir hier?
Was bin ich da?
Ja, man erkennt nicht so genau, was es ist.
Irgendwelche Variablenzuweisungen.
Das kann letztendlich alles sein.
Ich vermute aber mal, dass die Rakete bestimmt Blazingly Fast Written in Rust ist.
Okay, da habe ich mir noch gar keine Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Stimmt.
Das Ei gefriert ja, wenn man das zu hoch schweben lässt.
Ist halt kalt.
Ähm, meine blöde Frage, warum nimmt er nicht einfach die Eier?
Anstatt das Huhn zu verjagen.
Da brauchst du garantiert eine Genehmigung.
Also du brauchst auf jeden Fall, also ich weiß ja nicht, wie es bei den Amis ist.
Du brauchst auf jeden Fall irgendwas, irgendeinen Luftraum, wo keine Flugzeuge sind.
Und du musst das wahrscheinlich anmelden.
Sonst 100 pro, 100 pro.
Musst du, musst du das irgendwie anmelden.
Oder eben auf Gebieten machen, wo es erlaubt ist.
Keine Ahnung, garantiert.
Nicht, dass ein Flugzeug dagegen fliegt oder so.
Also am nächsten Morgen sind wir um 4 Uhr da, als die Wünsche die calmsten werden,
um unsere letzten Vorbereitungen zu machen,
zum Beispiel die letzte Minute Entscheidung,
eine metallische Streaming zu machen, um den Flugzeug zu machen,
damit es einfacher zu visualisieren.
Wir haben hier alles Redundanz.
Redundanzeige, Redundanzeige und Ignitere.
Marc hat zwei Servos auf der Fährung.
Keine dummen Fehler.
Und das ist genau, als wir unseren ersten dummen Fehler hatten.
Ups.
Warum konnten sie nicht einfach ein neues...
Ach so, weil die Befestigung nicht fest genug war.
Ach nee. Ah, okay, ich dachte, das wäre einfach nicht fest genug gewesen.
Verstehe, verstehe. Okay.
Okay, nur dass ich das jetzt richtig verstehe.
Die haben das Zeug an den Ballon gehängt.
Der fliegt hoch.
Dann releasen sie das.
Und sie haben eine Rakete dran hängen,
die quasi das Ei dann per GPS zurücksteuern soll,
über ihren Matratzen runterkommt.
Und kurz bevor es auf die Matratze haut,
klinken sie das Ei irgendwie aus.
Und okay, okay, verstanden.
Also da habe ich meine Zweifel, dass das First-Try funktioniert.
Es wird auch nicht First-Try funktionieren,
weil das Video geht ja noch 20 Minuten.
Warum rasten die immer so aus, alle?
Oh, da ist es.
Und während das Ganze wirklich cool aussieht,
haben wir schnell gemerkt, dass der Ballon
an einem schnelleren Zeitpunkt aufgerissen ist,
als wir erwartet hatten.
Wir sind bereits im Süden, und wir sind nur halb hoch.
Das hat total die gewünschte Tragektorie verschwunden.
Und so, nach ein paar Minuten,
haben wir die Rakete manuell geschlagen,
weil wir natürlich schon zu weit waren,
für die Rakete, um die latere Distanz der Matratze zu machen,
und dann haben wir es geschafft.
Oh Mann, das ist nicht gut.
Und das war das zweite Problem des Tages,
als die Finns aktiv die Rakete
in eine unkontrollierte Todespirale forderten.
Die Altitude ist 1.400.
Kommt man in den Weltraum, kommt man da nur mit einem Ballon hin?
Es ist wahrscheinlich die Frage,
was man als Weltraum definiert.
Also sprich, dort, wo gar keine Atmosphäre mehr ist,
da kommst du nicht hin mit einem Ballon.
Es gibt ja aber so verschiedene Definitionen,
ab wann, wie, wo, welche Stufe Weltraum ist,
und vielleicht kommt man da mit einem Ballon noch hin.
Oh, das sieht nicht gut aus.
And since we have the GPS cord into the rocket,
we headed out to track it down.
At which point we stumbled on an entire field of sitting birds,
which is another opportunity I'm not going to let just pass on by.
Is that a shoot, man?
Is that a shoot?
There's no egg.
The egg did release.
The fact that this is out means the egg did come out.
So that's good.
But despite that silver lining, the movable Finns...
Ist Waldo vorne wieder am abkacken?
Nö.
Nö, da kackt nix ab.
Alles gut.
...to be actually forcing the rocket into that tailspin,
which was surprising, because Joe had definitely run through a lot of analysis
and testing before coming here.
So after conducting a thorough review of the footage and firmware,
he was able to locate and fix a single rogue negative sign in the code
that seemed to be...
Ich will mal...
Ah.
Okay, jetzt erkennt man wenigstens, was es ist.
Okay.
Das ist C.
AvaSoft.
Was ist AvaSoft?
Ah, guck mal, es ist ein Platform IO Projekt.
Erkennen wir da vielleicht noch irgendwie sonst was?
Kennen wir da sonst noch irgendwas?
Ava ist der Name seines Flight Computers.
Aha, aha.
Also auf jeden Fall schon mal ein Platform IO Projekt.
Das ist schon mal eine gute Sache.
Das macht es einfacher.
Ansonsten erkennt man nicht, was es für eine...
Ah, hier unten vielleicht was.
Teensy ist das.
Wusste ich gar nicht, dass das überhaupt noch irgendjemand verwendet.
Das ist kein ESP32 und kein Arduino.
Das ist irgendein anderes Ding.
Teensy?
Ich glaube, ich gehe ein, dass es noch gibt.
Alles klar.
Ich würde es sehr begrüßen, wenn die Leute nicht alle immer so rumschreien würden.
Ansonsten ist das Video interessant, aber das Rumgeschrei nervt.
So.
Und was machen die damit?
Werden dann irgendwelche Wetterdaten gesammelt damit, oder?
Was ist der Sinn davon?
Okay.
Ah.
Ist das, dass man bessere Wettervorhersage bekommt, oder?
Aha.
Okay.
Das ist besser als Geocaching oder sowas.
Wetterballon caching.
Ist da irgendwelche Technik drin, die interessant ist?
Warum man das nicht so einfach macht?
Ich glaube, es geht ums Wetterballon caching.
Ist da irgendwelche Technik drin, die interessant ist?
Warum man die einsammeln sollte?
Ja.
Das sieht nicht nach Matratze aus.
Alter, schrei doch nicht so, Mann.
Das ist schrecklich.
Ah, hofft schon.
Wir waren immer noch weit weg von dem, wo wir sein mussten.
Das bedeutet es war Zeit für den ultimaten Freund von meinem Kumpel Adam Stelzner,
den man als dieser Typ kennenlernen könnte, von dem wir Kuryo-
Okay, also es hat anscheinend nicht wirklich funktioniert, das zu den Matratzen zu steuern.
Er hat einen Ph.D. aus Caltech und er ist auch Chief Engineer für Perseverance und Mars Sample Return.
Und so, nachdem Adam mir erklärt hat, was wir versuchen wollten,
hat er sofort eine fatale Fahne in unserem brillanten Plan gesehen.
Und du machst Terminalverwaltung zu etwas der Größe eines Hauses.
Wie wirst du das machen? Wie machst du das?
Ich meine, ich weiß, wie du das physisch machst.
Wie wirst du nicht von der FAA gebastelt werden?
In anderen Worten, wir wollten eigentlich einen präzisen gegründeten Missil machen.
Dude, es gibt Tausende von Leuten, die das vorher gemacht haben,
und sie wurden von der FEDERAL LAH geschworen, um nicht ein einziges Wort zu sagen.
Und um ehrlich zu sein, hat er einen guten Punkt erhofft.
Die Leute, die uns helfen können, können es eigentlich nicht.
Und auch wenn wir es selbst herausgefunden haben, sind die Ethiken von dem,
wie wir das Video auf YouTube machen, bestmöglich zu beantworten.
Und so, nach einer furchtbaren Diskussion mit Adam,
Aber wir sind an der Höhe des...
Das ist nur Kokona, glaubt man.
... zu loben.
Die Sache, die du anstecken willst, ist Heating.
Du möchtest vielleicht mit einem Zwei-Stage-Tag beginnen.
Wir haben uns entschieden, ein Pivot zu machen.
Und statt eines präzisen gegründeten Egglandings auf einer Mattress in einer kleinen Stadt,
würden wir unsere Sites auf einem viel mehr generalen Egglanding-Target setzten,
indem wir aus dem Meer reisen.
Aber als Teil des Pivots haben wir unsere alte Design komplett geschraubt
und haben ein paar Monate gearbeitet und ein neues System gebaut,
das sehr viel von der Curiosity-Landung zerstört.
Weil wir dachten, wenn es sicherlich ein Rover auf Mars gibt,
kann es sicherlich ein Egg auf der Erde landen.
Also würden wir immer noch auf einem Wetterballon in den Space gehen,
aber diesmal würde das Rocket Fins haben, das nicht bewegt,
und es wäre dreimal so lang und viermal so schwer,
um zu garantieren, dass wir das Egg zu supersonicen Geschwindigkeiten auf dem Weg nach unten bekommen würden.
Dann, wie NASA die Kruise-Stage in der oberen Atmosphäre separiert
und dann nutzt es Aero-Breaking, um eine Abwechslung abzuwenden.
Wir würden von der Rückseite des Rocketes, ungefähr halb weg runter,
nachdem wir bereits den Sound-Beruhr zerbrochen hatten,
und weil das jetzt viel weniger aufgewachsen ist,
würde es natürlich Aero-Breaken und seine Geschwindigkeit auf den neuen,
höheren Terminal-Velocity reduzieren.
Dann auf Mars, der nächste Schritt ist das Parachute-Deploye,
folgt von der Hink-Shield-Separation,
und wir würden uns von unserer eigenen Parachute ausführen
und dann unseren eigenen Nose-Kohlen ausführen,
welches dann unser Set von Kuschel-Airbags ausführt,
wie Sie hier sehen können,
welches wir von der Spirit und der Opportunity-Landung ausfüllen konnten.
Es ist fast so ein bisschen wie das, was ich am Anfang gesagt habe.
Ich würde so ein Aufblas-Bahn-Schwimmbad-Ball nehmen, ja.
Und ich würde so ein Aufblas-Bahn-Schwimmbad-Ball nehmen, ja.
Was machen die da mit dem Akkuschrauber da?
Ah, der zieht quasi das... okay.
Wisst ihr, was ich cool finde an der Stelle?
Wenn man sieht, was es für ein Riesenakt ist,
quasi einfach nur ein Ei an einem Wetterballon
hochsteigen zu lassen oder wieder runterfallen zu lassen,
da kann man, glaube ich, vielleicht im Ansatz
ein bisschen zu schätzen wissen, was es für ein Riesenakt ist,
wirklich Sachen ins Weltraum zu bringen,
Leute ins Weltraum zu bringen, die das dort überleben
und die sich ja wieder zurück auf die Erde zu bringen.
Sogar Leute auf den Mond zu bringen
und die sich ja wieder zurück zu bringen.
Also ganz im Ernst, das ist halt einfach
eines der größten Errungenschaften der Menschheit,
was wir je hinbekommen haben.
Deswegen finde ich es auch immer so cringe,
wenn dann irgendwelche Leute anfangen von wegen,
ja, die internationale Raumstation wäre unter Wasser,
die Mondlandung ist fake und generell, generell
ist das alles CGI und die Erde ist natürlich auch flach.
Ja, oder auf einem Asteroid landen
oder ein Teleskop so positionieren,
dass es eben quasi gravitationstechnisch recht neutral ist
und am Arsch der Welt driftet ja noch nicht mal,
so quasi fast schon am Arsch des Sonnensystems hinzufliegen.
Also da steckt schon so viel dahinter
und dass man das dann so komplett,
ja, so redet, als wäre das überhaupt nicht existent.
Ja, das stört mich teilweise schon.
Gerade diese ganzen Flat Earth-Geschichte auf YouTube
ist das so ein Ding, wo ich echt nicht verstehen kann,
dass das die letzten Jahre über so ein großes Teil geworden ist.
Ich meine, wisst ihr, es gab ja schon immer Leute,
die was von hohler Erde erzählt haben und sonstige Geschichten.
Jetzt ist es halt aktuell flache Erde.
Aber ich dachte eigentlich nie, dass die Leute das wirklich,
wie soll ich sagen, wirklich überzeugt davon sind,
sondern dass das eher so Rumgetrolle ist.
Aber wenn man sich da auf YouTube umguckt,
es gibt tatsächlich genug, die scheinen davon
unglaublich überzeugt zu sein.
Und es gibt noch ein paar andere, die schlagen da Kapital draus,
dass es ein paar überzeugte gibt und produzieren dann Content dafür.
Das sieht aus wie eine Plastiktüte vom Aldi.
Warum?
Was muss ich mir angucken?
Wo? Verschwörung?
Das kenne ich nicht.
Ich kenne ein paar Videos auf YouTube von einem Typ,
der sagt, dass Pinguine nicht existieren.
Weiß ich, ob das jemand von euch gesehen hat.
Das ist auch sehr lustig.
Also, auch Pinguine in Zoos und so, das ist alles Fake.
Das ist richtig Kekk, Alu-Time, Pinguine existieren nicht.
Genau
Ich bin ja auch nicht bei Twitch, der Wubblors ist ja bei Twitch
Da sind sie
Da sind sie in guter Gesellschaft
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, als vor ein paar Jahren bei der Internationalen Raumstation
irgendwelche Schläuche nicht aneinander gepasst haben
Weil die einen in Inches und die andere in Zentimeter gerechnet haben
Nur noch mal erwähnt ja
Wie kam es dazu?
Ich habe den Channel hier angelegt und den Namen einfach für einen Twitch-Channel, wo ich gucke. Ich wollte da gar nicht selbst streamen
Und irgendwann habe ich gar nicht streamen, selbst hab den Channel behalten. Hab den Namen halt behalten.
Ist gar nicht so schlecht, weil dann kommen bloß high IQ Leute von YouTube rüber
Chat, ich habe mal eine Frage an euch. Jetzt wollen wir gerade dabei sein
Muss ich, muss ich, okay ich muss das in zwei Fragen splitten
Wer von euch ist nur von Twitch da und kannte YouTube früher nicht?
Also kennt vielleicht jetzt mein YouTube, aber wer hat mich auf Twitch gefunden und nicht auf YouTube und nicht über YouTube?
Es sind nicht so viele, aber ich weiß, dass es ein paar gibt
Okay
So und jetzt und jetzt die nächste Frage. Würde es euch verwirren, wenn ich hier Max FPS anstatt Wubblors heißen würde?
Würde euch nicht verwirren
Umfrage jaans
könnte man machen
Fändet ihr es besser?
Und nächste Frage
Fändet ihr denn was anderthalbFX oder dreieinhalbして auf beim
gearbox
Fändet ihr es besser, wenn ich Max FPS heißen würde anstelle von Wubblors auf Twitch?
Okay, ich mach ne Umfrage.
Zusätzliche Abstimmung erlauben will ich nicht, dauere eine Minute.
Okay, mal gucken, mal gucken was rauskommt.
Wie kann der verwirrt sein, das ist eigentlich nicht möglich, der ist schon vergeben, der
ist nicht vergeben, der gehört mir, der gehört mir, der, ich hab mir das reserviert vor 10
Jahren oder so.
Okay, das ist wirklich ziemlich 50-50 man, das hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht, dass das
so 50-50 ausgeht, okay es geht genau 50-50 aus man, ja das eine ist genau 50-50, dann
doch Wub FPS, das hätte ich echt nicht gedacht, okay, ja dann bin ich jetzt genau so schlau
wie vorher, wäre Wubblors für YouTube, nee das geht nicht, Rundungsfehler würde ich
sagen, das war wieder klar, ja dann bin ich genau so schlau wie vorher, so wir gucken
das Video jetzt fertig, muss ich nur mal kurz einschieben, Wubblors heißt eigentlich gar
nix großartiges, ich musste irgendwas eingeben, als ich einen Twitch Account erstellt habe,
wie viele M-Bits hast du, 440 ab, Alter, was machen die da, Gachi-Buzz,
es gibt keine anderen Ballons, wirklich, ja ich glaube ihm das, aber für mich sieht
das aus wie ein übergroßer gelber Sack oder wie ein übergroßer Aldi-Tüte, wahrscheinlich
ist es deutlich komplizierter als einfach eine Aldi-Tüte, es hat eine große Aldi-Tüte,
nee, ich hab nicht automatisch mehr Upload bekommen, das musste man umstellen, Nico,
Dankeschön für den Sub, Wechsel, Dankeschön für den Sub, ah nee, ich hab mich verguckt,
der hat nur gefolgt, trotzdem, danke für den Follow, mal gucken, warte mal, ach, das
ist Werbung jetzt, Peck, das ist gefroren,
Peck, wirklich?
Ein Beachball!
Das ist aber nicht so ein Ball, wie ich meinte.
Ich meinte so ein Plastikding zum aufblasen.
Aber ich finde es lustig, dass sie auf eine ähnliche Idee kommen.
Er hat an dem Rover mitgearbeitet.
Der Typ, den er da befragt hat zu der Rakete, hat an einem Rover mitgearbeitet.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, dass es nicht kaputt gegangen ist.
Er schreit doch nicht so rum.
Ich finde es lustig, dass sie auf eine ähnliche Idee kommen.
Er hat wirklich Typen von der NASA mit dabei.
Aha.
Na gut.
GG Eats.
Ich finde es lustig, dass sie auf eine ähnliche Idee kommen.